[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
[Musique]
tous les dimanches soir à la Via noté à
porter mes clients Monsieur Philippe
Corti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Philippe Corti bravo merci
voici la bombe atomique voici Adriana
Karembeu
la vitesse
[Applaudissements]
et oui Adriana Karembeu là
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter Adriana Karembeu
la plus belle chose qui nous a été
envoyée par les pays de l'est vraiment
je dois vous dire si vous êtes
magnifique c'est la plus belle chose qui
est venue de l'Est depuis toujours voilà
merci alors vous êtes de plus en plus
mais je suis toujours gentil avec vous
et je vous trouve de plus en plus jolie
en plus vraiment
alors il y a un problème c'est que moi
quand je travaille chez moi comme ça
j'ai LCI allumé toute la journée sans le
son c'est juste pour avoir l'heure et
alors toute la journée il y a un spot
qui passe le quadriana Karembeu et quand
on voit le spot on dit comment il fait
pour bosser du sang merde
[Musique]
les gestes qui sauvent avec la
Croix-Rouge c'est un mannequin qui vous
les apprendra
si Adriana n'est pas là c'est Robert qui
s'en chargera
voilà
Adriana karembe dans le spot de la Croix
Rouge
sensibilisation du grand public ce qu'il
faut dire c'est qu'en France il y a
seulement 32% des gens qui sont formés
au premier secours alors qu'en
Angleterre ils sont 44 en Allemagne
s'étonnera personne ils ont réformé les
Allemands au premier égourt ils sont 80%
à être formés aux premiers secours nous
on est que voilà alors s'il y avait 20%
de la population française qui était
formée au 1er secours on saurait 10000
vies par an les premiers secours
[Applaudissements]
vous avez bien vu hein
ce qui se passe c'est que les gens
meurent avant l'arrivée des premiers
secours je dis ça marrant mais bon c'est
vrai que et pourtant ce sont des gestes
simples qui peuvent sauver d'ailleurs
Titeuf oui vous allonger là
oui
nous allons
là
[Applaudissements]
nous apprendre à tous les gestes qui se
faisaient beaucoup de chance Titeuf
parce que vous avez vu d'habitude c'est
Robert d'habitude c'est Robert c'est un
mannequin je te donne un petit
chewing-gum quand même
c'est la plage
complètement
alors
d'abord on protège la place on regarde
on va s'occuper de la victime
alors d'abord on va regarder si le
respire on va basculer la tête en
arrière
c'est pour sauver des vies
mais il respire très bien alors il
respire un peu vite même je pense oui
[Musique]
parce que il va tomber mais
normalement
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
m'intéresse au geste qui sauve
le côté le la position de survie voilà
vous êtes grand et bien
là
[Musique]
c'est important
sinon on fait deux fois
après on trouve le sternum il est là et
moitié
respire pas on appelle ça bien sûr
parce qu'on a besoin
on a besoin d'aide on a besoin
d'amour
bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]
on va voir si j'ai tout bien tout bien
compris tu vas t'allonger un peu sur le
alors on va rester dans les gestes qui
sauvent on va vous faire une interview
alerte rose pendant le jingle
[Musique]
et voilà tu n'as pas bougé vous n'avez
pas bougé pendant jingle et Adriana n'a
pas bougé non plus bravo Titeuf
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première fois que j'arrive à
faire à réussir un truc aussi dur c'est
vraiment c'est bien on voit que vous
avez répété bien alors l'interview
alerte rose si vous comprenez en
français vous répondez en français sinon
vous répondez en anglais et notre ami
traductrice qui est là je crois bien sûr
bien sûr tu es là toujours tout à fait
tu es prêt tu t'appelles comment Belinda
une chanson de Claude François bien
alors quelle est la première pensée que
vous avez Adriana Karembeu quand vous
vous trouvez en face d'un homme
séduisant
ce que je pense
maintenant je ne pense plus à rien à
l'époque dans le temps c'est Adriana je
vous dis tout de suite c'est pas
l'interview mensonge vous pouvez
répondre la vérité là
quel est pour vous Adriana le lieu idéal
pour une étrange
[Applaudissements]
si si la bonne personne tous les lieux
sont bons c'est parfait quel est
l'endroit Adriana Karembeu vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour une space
à cause de la pesanteur
ça doit être difficile déjà faut se
trouver avec les tenues
déjà pour s'embrasser avec le
vous préférez draguer ou vous faire
draguer
vous préférez vous faire vous préférez
larguer les mecs ou vous faire larguer
ai
vous préférez embrasser ou vous faire
embrasser
je préfère embrasser
caresser ou vous faire caresser
que vous arrêtez pas de regarder c'est
ça pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai et vous allez voir si on
peut si on remet le magnéto le micro
était était tombé le micro le petit
micro donc j'ai regardé j'ai dit tiens
il s'est remis en place et si on refait
un si on refait un ralenti on revient en
arrière vous verrez que le micro
d'Adriana était tombé comme ça
j'avais même pas remarqué
non non est-ce que vous conservez dans
la mode
Adriana est-ce que vous pensez est-ce
que vous conservez un fantasme
inavouable
vas-y
belindase
j'avais pas réalisé c'est encore dans
votre tête seulement oui oui
qui dit pourquoi je rentre pas sur le
plateau
5 minutes bien alors maintenant voilà
des gens qui m'envoient des questions
comme ça par email un dénométrie sans
Poirier alors il me dit vous demandez si
vous préférez vous demander aux gens si
elles vos filles si elle préfère un
homme infidèle qui fait bien l'amour ou
infidèle qui fait mal l'amour alors il
me dit au Moyen-Âge comme quoi c'est
vraiment une émission culturelle c'est
incroyable au Moyen-Âge il y avait les
poètes les poètes du Moyen-Âge il jouait
à des débats amoureux qui s'appelait les
jeux partis et alors ils avaient des
questions comme ça finalement on a rien
inventé au Moyen-Âge je vais déjà à ça
par exemple je posais c'est vraiment une
question du Moyen-Âge ça c'est c'est
historique c'est Tristan Poirier il
habite dans le 16e et très sérieux et
tout alors est-ce que vous préférez
posséder si vous deviez posséder la
moitié d'un homme vous préfériez avoir
le haut ou le bas
[Musique]
question du Moyen-Âge
vaut-il mieux croire que votre mec vous
trompe sans être sûr ou être sûr qu'il
vous a trompé mais le fera plus
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux croire que votre
mec vous trompe sans être sûr ou être
sûr qu'il vous a trompé mais qui le fera
plus la Belinda elle rame je suis sûr
mais là tu rames un Belinda
Christian a une autre femme dans sa vie
Christian ah bon il a une autre femme
dans sa vie c'est un jeu il a une autre
femme dans sa vie il vous reçoit les
deux le même soir dire vous et son autre
et sa maîtresse il vous reçoit les deux
le même sens un jeu
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux arriver deuxième
lorsque l'autre femme sort satisfaite ou
sortir satisfaite quand l'autre arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici Christian Karembeu
[Musique]
Christian Karembeu mesdames messieurs
bonsoir alors Christian on a beaucoup
d'admiration pour vous
admire beaucoup pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que vous faites partie des
Bleus donc vous êtes une star et
deuxièmement parce que vous êtes le mari
d'Adriana Karembeu qu'on a tous admiré
ici de nombreuses fois et qu'on est prêt
admirer encore très souvent je te le dis
Adriana bien alors Christian donc vous
êtes Canac
42 ça veut dire l'homme en colère c'est
ça non dites-moi si je me trompe c'est
ça ça veut dire un carambole c'est
quelqu'un c'est un statut guerrier quoi
c'est quelqu'un c'est très enfin je
crois que dans la nuit des temps dans
tous les peuples du monde ont donné des
noms par rapport à la nature aux arbres
etc aux pierres etc
c'est un guerrier un carambole alors
vous êtes né en 1970 à liffoux près
d'Ouvéa en Nouvelle-Calédonie donc qu'on
appellera la kaneki bientôt ça va être
indépendant la Nouvelle-Calédonie non
c'est en instance lui il a dedans alors
une histoire terrible dans votre famille
qui a été révélée par Didier desnax dans
un livre qui s'appelle les cannibales
c'est que les ancêtres de Christian
Karembeu ont été emmenés en métropole
comme on disait à l'époque pour être
exhibé à l'exposition coloniale de 1931
c'est une histoire absolument terrible
donc on les a mis nu dans une case
espèce de réplique grotesque d'une vraie
case kanak on les a mis dans des
costumes exotiques on les a obligés à
manger de la viande crue et on est
présenté comme des cannibales polygames
c'était un petit peu l'attraction comme
ça de cette fois exposition
d'attractions vedette et ensuite ce qui
est terrible c'est qu'ils ont été
échangés avec un zoo le zoo de Hambourg
contre des crocodiles c'est-à-dire
qu'après ils sont partis au zoo de
Hambourg
vous saviez pas vous c'était on en
parlait pas de ça chez vous
d'en parler cela dit j'en ai moi j'en ai
profité par de la mon statut de pouvoir
sensibiliser les gens d'abord sur mon
pays sur mon peuple et bien sûr parler
des miens oui
alors
ceci étant quand il y a eu le massacre
d'Ouvea
des Kanaks ont été achevés des canards
qui se rendaient les mains en l'air ont
été achevés par des gens qui portaient
l'uniforme de la République c'est un peu
la même chose d'une certaine façon et
c'est pas si vieux non on sait jamais vu
enfin je crois que il faut toujours
mettre chaque situation dans son
contexte
l'époque des miens c'était
justement le pouvoir colonial qui
existait qui existe toujours d'ailleurs
et par dessus par ce fait la France a
voulu démontrer justement l'étendue de
son pouvoir quand vous étiez petit on
vous a appris nos ancêtres les Gaulois
exactement
bien en fait quand vous étiez petit vous
étiez plus intéressé par le foot et les
footballeurs que par l'école et vous
connaissiez les joueurs de football par
la télé bien sûr mais aussi par les
magazines par les magazines comme France
Football comme 11 nous était repérés par
un ancien footballeur professionnel
s'appelle Marc gagnant qui a dit il faut
l'envoyer en métropole pour pour le
former alors votre mère
hésiter un peu vous lui êtes médecin
vous demandez c'était pas mieux de
rester là-bas et d'être médecin et
finalement vous êtes parti au centre de
formation de Nantes le départ ça doit
être terrible avec tout le monde qui
c'est toujours difficile de
se séparer du cocon familial surtout
dans ma culture où on est très la tribu
voilà en plus et
mais je crois qu'il y avait j'avais
envie de
casser un peu cette
smose mais en même temps grandir surtout
quand vous montez dans l'avion bon vous
êtes un peu triste un peu comme ça les
larmes aux yeux puis quand les portes se
referment vous dites voilà il faut que
j'ai simplement essayé mes larmes et on
me dit voilà il faut que je revienne
avec au moins une quelque chose
alors quand vous arrivez quand vous
arrivez en métropole alors évidemment
vous avez des 6 mois d'octobre il fait
froid vous avez des sandales vous n'êtes
pas du tout habillé pour la saison et en
décembre un jour vous habitiez près de
la gare un jour vous regardez par la
fenêtre et tout est blanc vous descendez
en caleçon dans la rue vous faites un
tour pieds nus dans la neige vous aviez
jamais vu de neige donc c'était quelque
chose pour vous
étonnant bah c'est
c'est merveilleux de pouvoir rencontrer
quelque chose quand on ne connaît pas
encore une fois très ouvert à la
découverte en fait parce que
[Musique]
ma philosophie est justement de toujours
connaître autant de monde mais en même
temps les découvrir mais avec
émerveillement et je suis toujours
surpris agréablement surpris de
connaître ce que je connais pas voilà
alors vous imaginez en plus que la
métropole c'est des gratte-ciel c'est
des des trucs ultra modernes et en fait
vous êtes très impressionné à Nantes
parce que c'est des vieilles maisons et
vous dit toujours j'ai l'impression que
je vais croiser d'Artagnan quoi parce
que tout ça est assez antique besoin on
peut rencontrer des pavés d'ailleurs il
y a encore la le château de la Duchesse
Anne qui existe encore
je voulais promenade de la Loire ou les
châteaux évidemment existent autour de
la Loire de l'herbe aussi donc là ça m'a
permis de revenir en arrière de pouvoir
côtoyer par côtoyer mais au moins
revivre des images de capdp et j'ai
pensé à d'Artagnan
voilà bon après il y a toute l'histoire
l'équipe de France
jamais été victime de racisme en France
non heureusement non non mais même les
oreilles se ferment
non parce que je crois que le silence
est une meilleure réponse à comme le
proverbe c'est ce que tu as à dire et
moins beau que le silence alors tais-toi
très bien parce que bon
les loges
scandale annonce régulièrement votre
séparation mais tout va bien tu vas très
bien on va voir comment ça s'est passé
je suis à tout le monde le connaît dans
super connu vous connaissez dans un bus
d'aéroport vous connaissez pas elle
tombe sur un type qui lui dit vachement
intelligent la question vous mesurez
combien déjà voilà comment draguer
Adriana Karembeu si tu veux et ben vous
vous saviez même pas qu'il était en plus
saviez pas que c'était un grand grand
joueur de foot lui il pensait j'ai
aucune chance il s'est dit une chance
tout le monde pense ça vous voyant et
vous vous dit et vous vous dites quand
les hommes me voient ils pensent
toujours j'ai aucune chance et voilà le
marchera jamais alors que c'est pas vrai
et ça on commence les mecs aussi
bon tous les deux alors c'est
le coupletin Island est-ce qu'on ne
regarde plus personne d'autre mais je
veux dire quand ils arrivent mais lui il
s'est vraiment un très bel homme donc il
est dit j'ai pas ma chance j'y crois pas
trop ah oui c'est quand même que si vous
rencontriez Adriana Karembeu dans un bus
d'aéroport vous lui diriez quoi pour la
pour la brancher est-ce que vous lui
diriez comme question
[Applaudissements]
et donc alors après bon il monte dans
l'avion tous les deux vous d'habitude
faites semblant de dormir quand vous
êtes dans un avion là vous gardez un œil
ouvert
il se met à côté d'elle et puis voilà
puis à la fin du voyage il vous a laissé
son chapeau ça c'est un truc à savoir
avec Adriana Karembeu il faut laisser
son chapeau parce qu'elle l'a beaucoup
ça vous a touché oui parce que qu'est-ce
que je peux faire qu'est-ce que je
j'ai rien j'ai rien sur moi elle n'avait
pas même pas même pas le valise rien
alors il m'a donné
et alors vous lui donnez votre numéro de
téléphone quand même assez rapidement la
première fois vous avez donné votre nom
normalement je fais pas ça
et alors deux jours plus tard il vous
appelle et vous l'invitez à prendre un
café mais comme vous êtes à Milan à lui
à Paris le mec il prend un avion là
c'est déjà plus déjà plus fort là il
vitamines t'en fais pas j'arrive
et un an après dans un restaurant fin du
deuxième conte de fée un an après dans
le restaurant il prend votre main comme
ça sous la table il enlève votre vieille
bague et se casse par une bague
vous vous êtes fait voler la bague de
votre maman et de notre papa non il lui
dit veux-tu être ma femme tu as le mec
que des trucs simples combien vous
mesurez est-ce que tu vas être ma femme
tu veux mon chapeau tu veux mon chapeau
nous on se fatigue je fais de la télé
pas du tout
fin du deuxième conte de fées voilà
et voilà
bravo
bravo alors vous dites au départ j'étais
pas séduit par la plastique d'Adriana
mais fasciné parce qu'elle est dans son
âme
qu'on est on aurait été quand même
fasciné d'abord par sa plastique non
je crois qu'elle venait de finir
un clip ou un travail en fait donc
j'étais ni bien maquillé ni oui donc les
cheveux un peu éborifient
sa prestance s'en allure qui m'a plus et
après quand j'ai plus lui parler voilà
mais vous dites après le vol Milan Paris
j'étais incapable de la décrire
physiquement donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui s'est passé au niveau du
regard effectivement
oui du regard du dialogue
je suis tellement conscient de l'aimer
que je ressens pas le besoin de
multiplier les démonstrations d'amour ce
qu'elle me reproche parfois lorsque je
rentre exténué et que je m'affalde
devant la télé Christian en merdes
non parce que en fait
ça c'est son c'est un petit détail mais
je crois que un sentiment en le donne
avec intégrité et on le donne pas pour
jouer ou je sais pas alors Adriana était
là en novembre on lui a fait l'interview
alerte rose et alors aujourd'hui on va
vous poser les mêmes questions pour
savoir si vous répondez pareil
je crois pas pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
quel est votre première pensée lorsque
vous vous retrouvez face à une femme
séduisante
je ne pense plus à rien lorsque je me
trouve en face d'un homme séduisant
vous croyez pas
alors bon on continue le lieu idéal pour
une étreinte pour vous
vraiment caché loin de tout le monde
c'est partout si je suis avec la bonne
personne
non mais c'est intéressant de voir parce
que bon il y a peut-être un ouverture
l'endroit Christian l'endroit où vous
seriez incapable de faire l'amour
enfin
parce que vous pensez l'amour c'est
seulement faire le coït mais moi l'amour
c'est aussi dans le regard dans le faire
partout
les Français on est comme des sauvages
quand elle a répondu dans l'espace elle
a dit dans l'espace je pouvais pas faire
l'amour dans l'espace parce que j'aurais
peur
des avions alors est-ce que vous
préférez draguer ou faire draguer
les deux les deux elle c'est se faire
draguer est-ce que vous préférez larguer
ou vous faire larguer
est-ce que vous préférez embrasser ou
vous faire embrasser
embrasser elle aussi
est-ce qu'on préfère les caresser ou
vous faire caresser
est-ce qu'il y a encore des fantasmes
que vous n'avez pas réalisé
si j'en ai oui j'en ai pas réalisé non
faut arrêter de regarder la télé si vous
deviez choisir la moitié d'une femme
vous prendriez le haut ou le bas
la moitié d'une femme
le ou le bas
mais la femme n'existe pas une notice
les rôles c'est le gage que j'avais
accepté allez viens
[Applaudissements]
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour la prochaine
vous avez 20 ans vous avez déjà fait 20
films X professionnels
de philo vous l'avez vu à l'âge de 18
ans c'est pour ça qu'on vous appelle 19
avec les chiffres et vous avez fait un
bien alors à 13 ans vous décidez de plus
manger de viande oui vous devenez
végétalienne ce qui n'est pas
végétarienne
la vie
pour ne pas
la nuit promet d'être belle car voici
confondue celle de la Caravelle la lune
rouge
[Musique]
chat séparément
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça
qu'est-ce qu'il fait
[Applaudissements]
encore
comment ça va Jacques et ben vraiment
très très bien
justement
une anecdote
racontez-moi ça
nous passions dans la rue avec ma fille
par hasard des trucs qui descend et qui
passe devant le Palais des Glaces
justement et alors on voulait aller
ailleurs mais tout était fermé ce soir
là et vous jouiez exactement l'époque
et vous allez voir le spectacle j'ai dit
à ma fille est-ce que ça t'intéresse de
voir quelqu'un qui fait rire les autres
elle m'a dit tout à fait parce que c'est
un enfant qui a beaucoup d'humour et
alors on a garé la voiture on est revenu
on a demandé ce qu'il y avait des places
on a payé
alors je vous demande combien
et après on est rentré dans le théâtre
c'était la première fois qu'on allait
dans un théâtre aussi tous les deux et
elle était très fière elle m'a pris par
le bras vous permettez une
reconstitution
elle était très fière et là regardez si
tout le monde la voyait et elle s'est
penché sur moi et on a attendu que le
rideau s'ouvre et quand le rideau s'est
ouvert elle s'est serré contre moi
correctement ça va pour la
reconstitution je sais pas moi ce que
vous avez fait mais ça lui a plu
vous étiez venu en fait parce que je
sais que dans les artistes ont terminé
j'ai envie d'être vous avez besoin de
VOUS éponger de vous voir vous avez
déclaré à 50 ans on commence à descendre
quand vous aviez 50 ans maintenant vous
en avez 60 vous pensez quoi c'est que ça
génère ça dit que ça dit sexe à Genève
donc ça va quoi c'est insensé parce que
en fait c'est 50 ans qui est dû après on
remonte après bon c'est sympa
quand on vous rappelle que vous avez dit
à 50 ans on commence à descendre vous
dites oui mais la descente est belle
vous avez cette phrase formidable avant
on était jeune et beau maintenant on est
beau bon on fait un peu de promo allez
allez si vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
c'est faux j'adore ce qu'il fait donc
c'est absolument pas quoi commencer à
faire un scandale c'est ça
non c'est simplement qu'on sort c'est un
peu con à faire ça quoi c'est pour ça et
tu préfères vas-y tu veux que ma femme
et moi on passe pour des cons
ça ça va mieux
oui
[Applaudissements]
alors le nouvel album de Jacques Higelin
c'est live 2000 donc c'est chez Warner
dans un label s'appelle tôt ou tard il y
a 10 titres parmi les meilleurs moments
de la dernière tournée si vous pouvez
nous en dire un mot
[Applaudissements]
zoom zoum mon garçon zoom zoum zoum zoum
zoum zoum zoum c'est lui qui a fait la
pochette ah c'est pas mal la pochette un
pochette zoom bien
bonsoir monsieur
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
donc vous avez collaborer avec Jacques
Higelin sur son dernier album qui
s'appelle live 2000
tu peux parler là
[Applaudissements]
alors
elle est géniale ton papa
il a tout un jeu de percussion énorme
quoi avec des timbales des
tambours des cymbales des gongs des
femmes soules
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi
donc je dis donc il y a dans cet album
vague à l'âme la vie est folle chambre
sous les toits Paris New York tranche de
vie Mona Lisa klaxon irradié champagne
l'accordéon désaccordé et ce qui est dit
doit être fait voilà
j'adore cette chanson le ver solitaire
je suis un genre de ver solitaire de
loup solitaire
quand j'étais au collège il y a ça il y
a 60 ans à peu près
on était très fan de vous évidemment
comme des gens de ma génération il y
avait la chanson le loup solitaire nous
on avait on avait transformé les paroles
pour les colos ça s'appelait je suis un
genre de verre solitaire à peine plus
gros qu'une vie et quand Jona mais je me
rappelle plus les paroles mais c'était
c'était une espèce de j'ai peur de vous
maintenant donc je suis avec ta fille
bonjour
Jacques quel est mon grand frère Mareva
non mais vous avez compris ce que je
voulais dire
cette femme vous êtes impérial on peut
avoir un plan sur cette femme qui est
impériale
[Applaudissements]
appelle plus gros qu'une invite et quand
je vais essayer des souvenirs
on était des gamins on était jeune on
avait à peine voilà à propos de verres
solitaire est-ce que je pourrais en
avoir un qui soit plein
oh joli
on y arrivera il s'apprendra le temps
qu'il faudra on arrivera au bout de
l'émission bon alors on va parler un peu
de votre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça n'est pas bien c'est toi là alors
Jackie Chan
pour comprendre votre pour comprendre
votre personnage un peu étudié votre
personne
je me trompe quand c'était requin de
folk vous avez une émission de flics
non pendant à l'époque de votre
naissance et de votre prime en France
c'était la guerre ouais voilà votre père
était prisonnier de guerre
un peu mais pas trop non plus et vous
vous aviez peur des bombardements de
cette
et c'est pour ça que vous avez gardé
cette détestation de la guerre de la
violence et du militarisme voilà déjà
quand on sait bien sûr on dit des fois
il arrête pas Higelin avec la guerre
l'antimitarisme et tout c'est normal
vous avez été élevé là-dedans non non
c'est simplement parce que même si
j'étais pas né là-dedans quoi parce
qu'après quand j'étais jeune homme il y
a eu la guerre d'Algérie aussi donc ça
faisait deux fois quoi que j'étais en
contact avec ça mais il y a quand même
beaucoup de monde qui est en contact
avec ça sur la planète quoi je trouve
simplement des armées tout le monde ce
serait enfin retirer les armes ce serait
déjà pas mal quoi se battre à Manu c'est
quand même plus non pourquoi tu me
regardes
faire des duels ouais ouais ouais
parce que la guerre ça laisse des traces
individus de faire attaquer des Noirs
par des bergers allemands par exemple
entre autres vous venez en plus Jackie
Chan une famille rebelle parce que dans
votre famille votre grand-père pour
échapper au travail dans les filatures
ce qui est un travail très restreignant
il est devenu traducteur d'un fakir oui
trapolsi ça plaît le Faki
il était aussi artiste votre père
je trouvais que Piaf chanté comme une
chèvre
ouais mais ça il avait il avait il avait
perdu noir en plus Pascal était habillé
en noir et me disait toujours elle est
cyniste c'était vraiment une autre
époque mais il aimait bien il aimait
bien entraîné chevalier ce qui fait que
vous avez commencé votre carrière en
fait en chantant du traîné et du
chevalier traque dans les cinémas voilà
accompagné par mon père
et là vous étiez un enfant assez spécial
quand même pourquoi parce que vous étiez
solitaire parce que votre temps à faire
l'école buissonnière vous voulez faire
de la j'étais pas fainéant en même temps
vous voulez faire de la musique du
théâtre la littérature donc vous aviez
envie de vous exprimer mais l'école
c'était pas votre truc alors votre mère
était complice pour vous faire des faux
certificats médicaux
alors c'est un concours
sister
quand vous après vous faites un film et
vous rencontrez un guitariste d'origine
gitane qui a composé pour montant et
Piaf et qui vous apprend la guitare son
nom Henri
ensuite donc voilà c'est vrai qu'avoir
Henri Rollin comme professeur de guitare
c'est pas mal
on continue la vie de Jacques Higelin
donc après au début des années 70
je ne pense pas donc ça vous intéresse
pas que je vous raconte votre vie vous
la connaissez vous ah ouais une scène
dans votre vie que moi je trouve
formidable c'est donc vous êtes un peu
faut dire un peu hippie un peu Baba à
l'époque un peu grande et tout et un
jour
et puis un jour vous allez avec votre
costume blanc et votre accordéon faire
la première partie de
que la première partie de cela est
familistone avec son costume blanc son
accordéon il se sent un peu ridicule
bien sûr et vous êtes un peu jeté par le
public oui oui Monique casse-toi virtuel
et j'ai commencé à l'accordéon j'étais
habillé tout en blanc devant une salle
qui était venue pour voir slide en
family Storm et j'ai commencé à jouer et
ça est devenu très houleux j'ai eu
l'impression moi d'être au milieu de la
tempête avec un mec sur un épave avec un
accordéon en train de chanter dans la
dans l'ouragan et puis un moment donné
ils sont calmés parce que j'ai continué
et quand ils sont arrêtés j'étais épuisé
j'ai posé l'accordéon et je leur ai dit
je m'en vais mais je reviendrai et je
reviendrai pas tout seul là je suis
sorti de concert je chialais dans les
escaliers là par où tout est danseuses
tous les musiciens arrivaient en
marchant dessus en plus et là j'ai été
j'avais pas beaucoup de ronge j'ai été
acheté un blouson à Saint-Ouen haute
puce votre camionnette était en panne en
plus ouais j'ai marché avec un jean et
tout et dit maintenant c'est la guerre
je vais faire du rock et je vais rentrer
dedans parce que je vois que
c'est la guerre quoi et bien décidé et
là j'ai démarré le truc à fond la caisse
est-ce que ma guitare est un fusil par
une New York et tout est-ce que tous ces
engagements et cette carrière très très
longue est-ce que finalement ça vous a
pas empêché un petit peu de vous occuper
de vos enfants ah pas du tout parce que
quand je lui parle Arthur H je lui
demande s'il s'entendais bien avec vous
et il dit je m'entendais d'autant mieux
avec lui qu'il était jamais là ah une
époque c'était comme ça mais c'est plus
comme ça et bon c'est expliqué et on
s'entend très bien ça va maintenant oui
c'est une époque où mais c'était une
autre histoire ça n'a rien à voir avec
Arthur c'est ce que je lui ai dit que
moi j'en souffrais autant que lui mais
il y a des moments où c'est des
histoires de d'amour de femmes voilà qui
fait qu'on quitte une femme pour une
autre et alors c'était autre chose quoi
mais c'est pas
j'en ai souffert aussi et je dis un jour
on a pleuré tous les deux j'ai dit moi
aussi ça m'a manqué terriblement quoi
mais bon c'est des choses privées aussi
et même pendant un temps il voulait pas
s'appeler Higelin parce qu'il était sûr
que les médias allaient dire il a la
copie de son père ou c'est son père qui
l'aide mais c'est pas moi qui ai aidé à
partir c'est sa mère qui l'a vraiment
aidé et
Arthur il s'est aidé lui-même parce que
moi je l'ai vu faire c'est un mec qui
s'est créé lui-même quoi et j'ai du
respect de ça je l'ai pas j'ai pas
comment tu dis les il marche ce [__]
de micro-ondes
un petit peu de gasoil là pour
bien alors comme vous êtes quelqu'un de
sincère Jackie gelain et vous venez de
le prouver en disant ce que vous venez
de dire au sujet de d'Arthur H on va
vous faire une interview mensonge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que vous n'avez pas bougé pendant
le jingle j'ai bougé les yeux
normalement on doit même pas qu'il y ait
des yeux pendant mais moi j'ai bougé les
yeux en rythme de haut en bas de gauche
à droite tout le temps mais je vous ai
pas vu ben voilà c'est ça la force de la
révolte
qui m'a pas vu quoi on va vous faire une
interview mensonge vous allez mentir il
faut que je monte pourquoi bah parce que
c'est une interview mensonge ah bon ça
va être dur pour vous non bien va voir
je sais pas j'ai déjà menti aussi c'est
vrai que vous avez une fortune en fait
et que vous avez beaucoup de beaucoup
d'argent qui est placé en action sur le
marché international alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut dire est-ce que tu as des
actions
est-ce que est-ce que vous baladez
toujours en limousine vitre fumée vous
faites allumer vos clubs par vos
assistants
ah oui ah bah ça évidemment
ça commence à rentrer
[Applaudissements]
ça aux hommes politiques il y a pas de
problème
vous êtes toujours inscrit à l'UDF
c'est quoi l'idéal
l'Union l'Union
évidemment bien sûr Jacques Higelin que
j'avais été obligé d'arrêter de fumer
des pétards pour pouvoir vous inscrire à
l'UDF
pendant parce que je fume des pétards
alors arrêtez attends il y a deux
mensonges à faire un truc contradictoire
quand même
des pétards
qui fume des pétales
sur le plan sexuel vous souhaitez
toujours sur tout ce qui bouge
non
qui fument des pétards
je sais ce que je dis arrêter de fumer
des pétards pour entrer à l'EDF
vous êtes quand vous faites votre
tournée en province ça vous fréquentez
toujours beaucoup les boîtes échangistes
oui
et là tu me regardes pas quand tu dis ça
parce que je veux pas te mêler à ça
non mais c'est quoi le plan là
cette histoire et cet été Saint-Tropez
avec la porno star
pourquoi comme ça c'est trop compliqué
dans une pinède à côté de Saint-Tropez
la fille comment
j'ai malin c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un manipulateur né on l'a
retrouvé morte dans une pinède à côté de
Saint-Tropez pinède ouais
dernière question Jacques Higelin très
très compliqué il interview mensonge
effectivement les hommes politiques ça
passe tout seul vous avez déclaré
j'aimerais mourir comme Elvis Presley
c'est-à-dire intoxiqué aux médicaments
au sucreries c'est vrai
ça c'est dur ouais oui oui parce que
dans le jeu oui oui j'ai rêvé ça
bon oui alors le résultat de ça c'est
quoi
c'est un test un peu grossier quand même
c'est assez lourd c'est vous qui êtes
lourd là ah bon j'y arrivais pas ah
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
vous avez du mal à mentir quand même
c'est bien c'est bien on a vu là que
vous n'alliez pas à mentir votre femme
doit être ravi
on va expliquer donc à nos amis
téléspectateurs le jeu du homard donc si
des fois il y avait des execos blind
test alors le principe est simple il
suffit de tomber en même temps que le
homard et si des fois il y avait un
petit doute on ferait un petit replay
Serge attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pardon
le replay au ralenti c'est ma fille qui
aurait gagné
en regardant en regardant le replay
[Applaudissements]
et oui
madame monsieur
[Applaudissements]
et oui
[Musique]
j'appelle Boris le cas de Fourqueux il a
envoyé un email en disant qu'il voulait
participer au jeu du homard Boris
[Applaudissements]
et pour se poser à Boris le cap bonsoir
asseyez-vous j'appelle de nouveau moi
j'ai vu les Bugatti
le principe hein
comme ça vous vous mettez comme ça voilà
vous êtes tombé en même temps que le
homard
[Applaudissements]
Serge qui a gagné qui a gagné replay top
replay attention
[Applaudissements]
Philippe Corti
si vous aussi vous voulez affronter
Philippe cantine dans le jeu du homard
vous envoyez les emails et peut-être
vous serez admis à vous affronter à
Monsieur Philippe Corti voilà voici
maintenant un beau mec voici Samuel Le
Bihan
c'est vrai que là
cette fois faut arrêter de râler les
filles parce que vous avez vraiment une
belle brochette là CAD Olivier tu
regardes pas ma meuf comme ça Samuel
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est passé de Corse à arménien en une
émission bien il a pas encore parlé
Samuel non non mais Samuel il s'en fout
les couilles
ce soir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est Bernardo
bon le Pacte des Loups donc ça s'appelle
cette superposition française c'est un
film de Christophe gant avec Monica
Bellucci donc Vincent Cassel émilie
Dequenne qui jouait dans Rosetta Jean
Yanne Jean-François Stévenin Jacques
Perrin Bernard Fresson enfin il y a un
casting d'enfer dernier aussi c'est vrai
cette histoire quand vous êtes arrivés
sur le tournage vous avez dit que la
caravane de Vincent Cassel était plus
grande que la vôtre c'est vrai que ça me
faisait chier de me sentir inférieur que
j'avais pas envie de me dise voilà là il
y a la star et toi tu es alors je vais
le même âge dans le même film
votre boulot vous êtes un artisan
vous dites il y a plein de manières de
faire ce métier
il y a le mec pépère tranquille qui fait
un petit film parent bon il y a le mec
qui passe ces soirées à prendre de la
coke ou de l'Hérault et dans les soirées
vous êtes l'artisan vous croyez la force
du travail
autour d'école vous dites d'ailleurs la
fierté on va la chercher dans les sales
coups dans le risque et quand on pique
quelque chose ben ça devient héroïque
quoi c'est-à-dire que vous ce qui vous
rendez héroïque c'était pas les premiers
les bonnes notes vous n'étaient pas
premier de la classe c'est
les pic de conneries que vous faisiez
quoi ouais les petites conneries mais
j'ai jamais été un méchant de toute
façon vous avez plus mal finir quand
même
j'aurais pu continuer les conneries mais
j'ai eu des bonnes rencontres oui c'est
ça il y a un mec un soir vous avez
discuté avec lui il sortait de prison le
mec mais j'en étais pas là non plus
parce que le mec vous a dit moi j'ai
raté ma vie c'est pas la même connerie
quoi alors le déclic pour vous c'est
incroyable et moi ça me fascine
l'histoire des gens c'est-à-dire qu'un
jour vous allez vous accompagner les
copains en cours Florent et vous dites
finalement ça a l'air sympa ce métier à
l'époque vous vouliez faire les
beaux-arts et vous dites c'est sympa et
je vais faire comédien ça où escroc
mais le problème si vous avez été obligé
d'arrêter le Cours Florent par manque de
fric parce que voilà et vous partez
faire le tour d'Europe alors ça c'est
incroyable quel courage portez faire le
tour d'Europe dans les rues alors bon il
manquait la parole mais en même temps
c'est c'était du jeu quoi et puis voilà
il y a une rue il y a rien et on se dit
là il va y avoir un théâtre il va y
avoir des spectateurs et je vais faire
un spectacle et avec ça je me
débrouillais je gagnais bien ma vie donc
je voyageais du feu je l'ai appris un
moment j'ai rencontré cracheur de feu il
m'a appris à
le faire un petit peu voilà c'était
marrant il y a il faut
un petit peu comme ça vous marchez sur
les mains
il sait faire ça Olivier Picasso non
encore après retour de cette de ce
voyage quoi donc vous faisiez le mime
vous faisiez du spectacle de rue
vous présentez le conservatoire et je
vais faire une scène de bagarres
original ouais et vous amenez vos maps
parce que vous dites on va pas leur
casser leur meuble ils nous ont pris
pour des fous quoi
bien sûr mais en même temps vous êtes au
Conservatoire vous partez un an à New
York vous vivez à Harlem vous vous
déchargez des camions dans le Bronx dans
ma New York j'en ai j'en ai chié j'en ai
vraiment chier mais mais voilà j'ai
appris tellement de choses et puis
c'était un espèce de parcours
initiatique je voulais apprendre j'avais
la fascination des de l'Amérique ben
voilà j'ai pris ma claque et j'étais
content quoi et aujourd'hui ça va très
bien
ça ouais ça va vous commencez à gagner
des sous là oui j'ai vu vous annoncer
combien vous gagnez c'est pas mal payé
donc non Jean y gagner toujours 700 800
000 balles par film avant et là pour le
Pacte des Loups il a pris un million 8
quand même ça coûte se faire chier dans
la boue à Saint-Chély-d'Apcher
60 % impôts quand même oui bien sûr il y
a l'agent il y a tout le monde qui
croque mais bon c'est énorme quand même
ce que je dis ça représente ce qui en un
an je gagne ce que mon père a gagné en
toute une vie donc faut mettre les pieds
sur terre bah c'est bien voilà en même
temps on est content pour vous en même
temps ça je suis libre
vous avez profité maintenant vous êtes
un peu calmé vous avez bien profité de
votre succès quand même vous êtes non
mais c'est vrai les boîtes vous avez pas
le droit de rentrer bah vous y êtes
allés pour voir comment c'était à
l'intérieur les restos où on peut jamais
aller parce qu'on n'a pas de thunes vous
allez pouvoir ce qu'on mange et comment
voilà et puis il y a eu aussi les filles
quoi vous dites et voir nu des filles
j'aime bien cette phrase et voir nu des
filles inaccessibles
ça va le jour on fait des déshabiller
la fille que tu vois en photo dans elle
si tu veux jouer devant toi tu dis merde
c'est bien tu l'as rencontré la baratine
mais bon oui je suis parti un petit peu
dans tous les excès parce que je voulais
j'avais une fin de signation pour ça et
du temps à attraper bien sûr
alors vous dites certains couches pour
réussir moi j'ai réussi pour coucher
non non mais c'est vrai
alors maintenant ça va être terrible
pour vous
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bougé merde à cause de toi
est-ce que vous préférez votre père ou
votre mère
j'ai averti
c'est pas possible je peux pas répondre
à ça je peux pas
mon Seigneur dit Falco qui attend là-bas
rassurez-vous Monseigneur c'est
interview on l'a fait à Samuel Le Bihan
donc vous y avez échappé des facto et
alors plus simple est-ce que vous
préférez Staline ou Hitler
alors ça c'est déjà plus simple
vous êtes trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial
est-ce que vous préférez partir avec
Kadéo ou Bataille et Fontaine
tu dis ce que tu veux on t'en voudra pas
dis ce que tu mets
un peu plus j'ai déjà vu leurs émissions
bonne journée
[Musique]
bien alors vous partez
nous partirons
dans votre émission le pense à quéquette
c'est pas trop service public ça quand
même alors [__] vous partez sur une
île déserte si vous partez sur une île
déserte est-ce que vous préférez partir
avec un mec très beau ou une fille très
laide fille très laide vous êtes pas
[__] du tout
mais pas du tout
désolé
bonjour bonjour
[Applaudissements]
Est-ce que vous accordez plus de
circonstances atténuantes un vieux qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui tape
sur des vieilles
c'est quel âge les petites
14 ans à 14 ans je préfère celui qui
tape les vieilles
[Applaudissements]
punition préférée c'est être pincée
mordu ou piqué
un mordu j'aime bien
le mot le plus con en amour c'est merci
encore ou oui oui
ça dépend dans quelle langue
foutu
alors Samuel si vous aviez un perroquet
vous ayez un perroquet vous lui
apprendriez quoi comme phrase tu as
fermé le gaz
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
la coco
ah oui ça c'est terrible ça vous trouvez
votre fiancé au lit avec deux par Dieu
ça c'est chiant
qu'est-ce que vous faites
vous restez
qu'est-ce que vous faites alors vous
restez et vous mettez au lit avec eux et
je regarde où vous regardez oui vous
gifler votre fiancé vous boudez vous
tuez vous parlez le boulot
sodomise de par Dieu
Catherine me dit c'est vrai Catherine ça
pose le fils de l'émission elle dit pour
un mec qui est pas [__] il sodomise
facilement de par Dieu
ah ouais bien vu Catherine bienvenu
voilà
Samuel Le Bihan donc à la fiche du Pacte
des Loups de Christophe danse qui sort
le 31 janvier
voilà alors on compare souvent cette
émission à un dîner en ville et dans
tout bon dîner en ville qui se respecte
il y a un évêque voici Monseigneur dit
Falco
[Applaudissements]
Monseigneur dit Falco bonsoir bonsoir
Kad Alice events Olivier Patrick fioriot
ah oui c'est vrai ah oui c'est vrai
exactement
alors vous êtes évêque auxiliaire de
Paris
chargé des communautés catholiques
étrangères des prêtres étrangers des
relations avec l'Islam et le judaïsme
vous êtes responsable de la
communication du diocèse de Radio
Notre-Dame et d'une chaîne de télé
catholique qui s'appelle catho KTO
vous le saviez
quand vous parlez de la télé vous dites
la télé c'est comme une religion il y a
une liturgie il y a une célébration à
heure fixe et c'est pas par hasard qu'on
appelle le journal télévisé la
grand-messe d'ailleurs vous avez vu je
suis habillé en quart d'Human moi
la prochaine fois
prenez-le
c'est la première fois de ma vie là
à partir du moment où tu vas mettre ça
Thierry plus de sexe mais attention
si vous le prenez vous le gardez surtout
au mois d'août et vous verrez comme
c'est agréable
non très chaud
ça va me valoir 150 lettres à peu près
ça va bien mais vous l'avez mis à
l'envers
parce que ça fait un peu comme ça
vous dites en parlant de la chaîne de
télé donc KTO
[Rires]
je vis un petit peu comme un moine
donc alors vous dites que vous créez une
chaîne de télé c'est comme construire
construire une église c'est-à-dire que
c'est pas relever un défi mais c'est
accomplir un devoir dire que finalement
il est naturel que l'Église la vocation
de l'église la communication et il est
naturel que l'Église communique c'est
comme quand elle faisait des des façades
de cathédrales finalement ça
communiquait bah il y a eu les livres il
y a eu la radio il y a internet la télé
donc il est naturel que l'Église et une
chaîne de télévision oui si on considère
que la place publique est temps modernes
c'est la télévision autrefois lorsqu'on
voulait s'informer on sortait de chez
soi on est sur la place du village pour
rencontrer les autres pour écouter ce
qui se disait aujourd'hui c'est
l'inverse si on veut s'informer on
rentre chez soi on regarde la télévision
donc si l'Église va être présente dans
cette polyphonie de tout ce qui se dit
de tout ce qui s'est mis je alors euh
voilà il faut pas le dire non non parce
qu'après lui
donc ce lieu d'échange de dialogue bien
si elle veut être présente il faut
qu'elle soit aussi présente dans le
cadre de la télévision alors cette
chaîne donc Katou on la trouve sur nous
en région parisienne et sur Canalsat au
niveau européen voilà alors il y a quand
même 5 millions de de gens qui
pourraient la regarder en tout cas si
vous la regardez ça marche bien oui avec
des moyens très modestes mais oui oui ça
marche bien alors on va parler d'actu
puis après on parlera de choses un petit
peu plus fondamentale ouais ouais parce
que là je sens que c'est vous avez ça
toute la journée autour du cou quoi
terrible bon on s'habitue c'est comme
une cravate non mais je sais mais ma
femme quand elle a son collier de chien
allez merci merci alors
Monseigneur dit Falco vous vous êtes
vous êtes un immigré finalement vous
êtes la troisième génération
de d'Italie et de Corse voilà qui sont
arrivés à Marseille donc finalement vous
êtes un travailleur immigré enfin votre
famille en tous cas c'est des
travailleurs immigrés
c'est une famille qui était catholique
mais pas pratiquante et vous alliez à la
messe en cachette quand vous étiez petit
je servais la messe en cachette jusqu'à
ce que la crémière me dénonce alors bah
vous avez pas une enfance très drôle
vous non plus mais enfin vos parents se
séparent vous êtes très jeunes vous
grandissez dans 20 mètres carrés à
Marseille avec votre mère et votre sœur
votre père vous l'avez revu 42 ans plus
tard donc c'est pas hein c'est pas dû
être une enfance très drôle et un jour
vous avez un flash quoi c'est à dire
qu'il y a une voisine qui vous emmène à
la messe à la paroisse Saint-Just
et là qu'est-ce qui se passe
bien là c'est une image en fait que j'ai
gardée je vais avoir trois ou quatre ans
sans doute je suis entré pour la
première fois dans une église et le
souvenir que j'ai c'est à la fois
l'ambiance assez sombre de l'église et
puis au bout de ce tunnel quelque chose
de très lumineux j'étais l'hôtel Le cœur
qui était illuminé et à partir de ce
jour-là sans trop savoir ce que ça
voulait dire quand on me demandait ce
que je voudrais faire plus tard je
disais je voudrais que je voulais être
prêtre sans vraiment savoir
alors après bon bah vous grandissez ce
désir est un petit peu en sommeil et un
jour dans votre paroisse il y a le curé
le vicaire qui tombe malade en même
temps le curément d'ailleurs et là les
jeunes de la paroisse prennent un petit
peu à coeur de les remplacer et là vous
sentez ce désir de d'être prêtre revenir
et vous prenez le relais vous faites
toutes les toutes les tâches qui
incombaient habituellement au prêtre et
au vicaire et là l'appel est impérieux
et vous dites il faut que je sois
disponible pour le Christ et bien à ce
moment là je pense que si je peut être
heureux il faut que je réponde à cet
appel je peux dire que c'est un choix
difficile parce que j'avais 18 ans
j'étais très amoureux
et j'ai dû faire un choix
que j'ai fait mais c'est vraiment je me
suis trouvé confronté à ce choix là oui
c'est à 18 ans vous vous étiez avec une
fille d'ailleurs vous dites c'est elle
faisait une médicale la fille vous dites
c'est l'époque a changé on n'osait pas
se prendre la main à peine c'est à peine
faire et quand vous lui avez annoncé à
cette fille votre intention de devenir
prêtre comment elle a réagi
dans ce cas là quand on aime quelqu'un
mais
c'est un peu de souffrance et de
tristesse après très bien et lorsqu'elle
s'est mariée avec un de mes amis je suis
devenu le parrain de son dans son
premier enfant vous avez un an de plus
que vous
c'est tout c'est extraordinaire
vous avez déclaré dans le Figaro Madame
en 92
dans la vie de prêtre renoncer à la
sexualité
n'est pas une chose acquise une fois
pour toutes il peut lui arriver comme un
homme marié d'être infidèle à ses
promesses
c'est une épreuve douloureuse mais c'est
pas pour autant qu'il restera enfermé
dans le péché toute sa vie c'est
impossible quand même est-ce que ça veut
dire que vous admettez
la source donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
noté la source je sais que ça peut
prêter à la discussion mais enfin dire
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il restera
enfermé dans le péché toute sa vie ça
veut dire que vous n'êtes pas si bien
non mais ça veut dire que vous AD donc
un prêtre peut craquer un moment c'est
pas le fait que j'admettre ou pas dans
dans une vie d'homme que l'on soit prête
ou que l'on soit marié il peut arriver
en effet que que l'on soit infidèle à sa
femme comme infidèle au choix qu'on a
fait c'est pas pour autant qu'on reste
dans cette situation de façon définitive
et on peut donc sortir de cette
situation alors en même temps il faut
pas généraliser et dire c'est le cas
pour tous les prêtres mais ça peut
arriver dans une maison est-ce que en
parlant du célibat des prêtres c'est là
où je comprends pas vous dites il a
jamais été autant nécessaire
qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a une telle
confusion entre l'amour et le désir
qu'il est important qui est d'un côté le
désir de l'autre côté de l'amour c'est
pas complètement la même chose et le
célibat des prêtres est très important
oui je voulais dire sans doute que à une
époque justement on a tendance à faire
cette confusion entre l'amour avec un A
majuscule et puis le fait que on se
rencontre un soir un dîner on se trouve
sympa on couche ensemble et puis on se
revoit plus c'est pas de l'amour ça
désire donc que des hommes et des femmes
grâce à notre choix
pour montrer qu'il est possible d'aimer
autrement et que l'amour peut aussi se
déployer s'exprimer autrement que dans
la sexualité ou dans le mariage bien je
pense que c'est un témoignage dès
l'instant où il est choisi
volontairement que l'on peut donner mais
de l'amour oui bien sûr ma femme moi je
fais quand je vois par exemple des
prêtres des curés comme ça qui sont
arrêtés ça arrive il y en a quand même
beaucoup chaque année qui sont arrêtés
pour des agressions sexuelles sur sur
des sur des enfants moi j'ai honte
d'être catholique quand je vois ça je
vous dis franchement j'ai honte et moi
je suis contre le célibat des prêtres à
cause de ça parce que je me dis que si
ces mecs là ils avaient une vie normale
s'ils avaient une femme comme le rabbin
à une femme comme le pasteur a une femme
il serait pas obligé de se jeter sur des
gamins ou des gamines de 15 ans
j'entends bien ce que vous dites mais
vous oubliez peut-être aussi que parmi
ceux qui se trouvent dans ces situations
il y a également des pères de famille et
des hommes mariés
une période où j'étais vers l'âge de
15-16 ans que j'étais très un peu
désespéré je suis allé voir un curé et
j'ai parlé avec lui non mais c'est
sérieux et il m'a donné beaucoup de
force et beaucoup d'aide et j'ai lu les
évangiles
il m'a donné sans j'ai été baptisé mais
j'ai pas fait ma communion donc il m'a
donné la permission de de prendre le
style de communier et
ça a duré un an et puis après bon j'ai
pas j'en voulais à Dieu quoi j'avais du
mal à admettre en fait un petit peu
j'avais du mal à comprendre la relation
entre Dieu qui vous donne de la force et
toute la souffrance qui a sur la terre
c'est un peu généraliste mais avec mes
yeux de 15 ans j'avais du mal à faire la
jonction et
mais ça m'arrive encore de prier parce
que ça me donne beaucoup de force ça me
permet de me repérer mais voilà bon le
seul voilà le seul acte véritable c'est
d'avoir lu les évangiles quoi mais c'est
je dirais que c'est principal c'est
l'acte fondamental ce qui est fascinant
les évangiles c'est que on peut le
prendre à n'importe quelle page quoi
quoi qui nous arrive on peut le prendre
à n'importe quelle page et des filles
qui comptent dans les deux pages de
lecture de pas trouver la solution à son
problème de pas trouver la force
et puis oui moi je peux je l'ai dit dans
dans certains journaux mais oui mais je
je fais ma prière quoi c'est clair avant
de rentrer je me suis signé tout
simplement ici ça va devenir parce que
je
fais que tout se passe bien à faire le
signe de la croix avant pour en revenir
à notre discussion c'est vrai que le
message du Christ et le message le plus
révolutionnaire de tous les temps parce
que c'est en vivait il faut bien
souvenir quand on vivait dans une époque
d'esclavage à l'époque il y avait des
esclaves dans la Grèce antique dans la
Rome antique et les esclaves bon et puis
un jour il arrive et il dit on est tous
frères aimez-vous les uns les autres
c'est le message le plus révolutionnaire
de tous les temps c'était évident mais
c'est vrai que ce message est souvent
brouillé pour le pour le public moi je
le vois autour de moi par finalement des
positions réactionnaires de l'église
alors prenons les exemples concrets le
préservatif par exemple le pape et
contre le préservatif le pape n'a jamais
parlé du préservatif genre mais dans
aucun texte la position de l'église sur
cette question du préservatif et la
suivante
si vous voulez vivre l'idéal de votre
foi je dis bien l'idéal de votre foie et
bien si vous êtes marié vous êtes fidèle
et avant votre mariage vous n'avez pas
de relation sexuelle si vous voulez
vivre l'idéal mais si vous ne parvenez
pas à vivre cette idéale là c'était
évident que vous non seulement vous
pouvez mais que vous devez utiliser le
président
ni suicidaire ni criminels je
connaissais quand on n'est pas capable
de faire l'abstinence disant
c'est-à-dire de pas baiser ou qu'on est
incapable évidemment on a le droit de
mettre des présences
vous éteignez chez vous et on est ici
aussi
donc ce que vous dites Monseigneur dit
Falco ce soir c'est que un catholique
peut très bien utiliser un préservatif
et tout le monde puisse aider
préservatifs c'est pas condamné par le
Vatican
à partir du moment vous ne parvenez pas
à vivre l'idéal de fidélité par exemple
et que vous avez des relations sexuelles
et bien vous ne pouvez pas prendre de
risques d'être soit criminel soit
suicider il faut utiliser le préservatif
je crois des questions de bon sens ça
c'est la position de Monseigneur Di
Falco qui est à Paris
de façon claire de l'église
[Musique]
ça ouvre des horizons quand même alors
maintenant alors toujours sur ces
problèmes-là finalement ce sont des
problèmes bon l'avortement vous
dites-vous sur l'avortement vous dites
quand on est contre la peine de mort on
doit être contre l'avortement bon donc
l'église quand même contre l'avortement
il y a pas de discussion là-dessus pas
bon la pilule pareil à l'église est
contre la pilule tout moyen de
contraception artificielle
le préservatif s'il est utilisé dans le
sens que vous dites il est un moyen de
contraception mais il se trouve qu'il
est aussi un moyen de protection contre
une maladie alors donc soyons clairs
donc l'avortement non la pilule non le
stérilet non enfin
toute la liste parce qu'elle a des trucs
il y a des moyens préservatifs qu'on
peut pas il y a les moyens pour pas
avoir d'enfants qu'on peut pas raconter
la télé
l'euthanasie non non vous êtes quand on
est contre la peine de mort on est
contre l'euthanasie c'est j'imagine tous
résume dans le fait que la vie la vie de
notre en appelant le droit de décider de
la vie ou de la mort de notre être
humain même lorsque il est atteint par
une maladie grave je crois mais je
comprends très bien tous les arguments
je me place moi sur le plan humain si je
me trouvais dans cette situation je
comprends les arguments mais je crois
que pour comprendre la position d'église
par rapport à ça il faut se dire qu'à
partir du moment où on commencerait à
introduire des exceptions jusqu'où ça va
en fait c'est ça c'est à partir du
moment où on dit mais dans telle
conditions peut-être qu'il faut on
pourrait envisager qui va qui va le
gérer ce qui va se présente pas d'argent
tu es une fille voilà et c'était une
famille qui a déjà 8 enfants ils veulent
faire l'amour ils peuvent pas faire
l'amour parce qu'ils ont pas de
préservatifs
les évangiles enfin la religion c'est
pas fait pour être pour épouser l'air du
temps c'est une morale c'est une loi
bon ça dépend quel jeu
on a vu alors le les couples homosexuels
est-ce que l'Église admet qu'un homme
vivent avec un homme se pacs ou une
femme avec une femme
non mais je sais pas j'ai droit à tout
là non mais c'est normal mon seigneur
je pense pas seulement pour l'Église une
famille c'est un homme et une femme
néanmoins pour régler un certain nombre
de problèmes de couple homosexuel elle
n'était pas opposée au fait que que la
législation soit revue et que ce soit
réglé par ce biais là un certain nombre
de questions ce qu'elle n'admet pas
c'est qu'on met sur le même plan la
famille
constitué de noms et d'une femme et puis
un couple homosexuel qui s'agisse de
deux hommes ou de deux femmes alors vous
avez vu il y a un livre qui est sorti là
qui est un livre important que c'est un
livre de René Raymond on en a parlé
d'ailleurs la semaine dernière ici
c'est un livre où René Raymond dit que
finalement aujourd'hui la religion
catholique en France et victime enfin
toute proportion gardée évidemment de la
même intolérance ont été victimes le
judaïsme à l'époque
maltraiter sarcasme etc et c'est vrai
quand on voit au guignol le qui prend de
la coke par exemple on n'a jamais vu le
grand rabbin prendre de la coke ou le
recteur de la Mosquée de Paris prendre
de la coke alors est-ce que ça vous par
rapport à ça vous réagissez comment
c'est vrai qu'un certain ras-le-bol par
rapport à ça et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a le sentiment que le
catholicisme le christianisme le
catholicisme en particulier de sorte de
bouc émissaire il se trouve que nous
quand on roule dans la farine ou dans la
boue on ne menace personne de mort voilà
peut-être que d'autres ont d'autres
moyens qui font que chacun avait fait
une ceinture
du Coran sur la ceinture c'est pas dans
notre action
de menacer les gens de mort alors c'est
peut-être pour ça que ben on se permet à
certaines personnes pour les Guignols
sans doute
en Angleterre il soit plus facilement
oui je disais en même temps bon c'est de
l'humour quoi c'est de la blague faut
qu'on puisse aussi se moquer de l'église
bien sûr mais parfaitement qu'on se
moque de de l'église et qu'on nous
caricature pourquoi pas mais je crois
qu'il y a des moments où ras-le-bol bien
alors maintenant on va passer mon
Seigneur dit Falco à lardivio ne bouge
pas pendant le jingle
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très bien
j'ai l'habitude de pas bouger parce qu'à
la messe aussi il y a des mauvaises
bouge pas on doit baisser la tête et
tout donc c'est un peu pareil finalement
c'est une espèce de grande messe ici le
samedi soir vous pensez à quoi là
mais je vous disiez c'est une espèce de
je disais oui de liturgie vous vous
dites quoi le matin quand vous vous
voyez dans le miroir
j'évite de me regarder à ce moment-là ce
qui vous énerve le plus en vous la chose
que vous supportez le moins chez vous
ma gueule pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'elle a
ta gueule parce que non parce que parce
que c'est tellement l'objet tellement
été l'objet de de coliber de toutes
sortes que pourquoi je préférerais avoir
quelques visages plus anonymes ah non
mais vous avez vous avez une tête pour
faire de la télé attendez arrêtez
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est bien
attendez Chamberlin est-ce que vous
seriez prêt à tout quitter pour le grand
amour alors imaginez non mais
sérieusement vous rencontrez une fille
comme ça non mais est-ce que vous seriez
prêt à abandonner votre état de prêtres
est-ce que vous l'imaginez ça ou est-ce
que vous rentrez maintenant c'est très
difficile ce projeter dans cette
situation là à froid à froid là je vais
vous dire non
mais je n'ai pas arrivé mais bien sûr ça
peut arriver je ne pourriez tout quitter
pour le grand amour je ne sais pas vous
dites pas non qu'est-ce que vous faites
la dernière chose que vous faites avant
de vous coucher le soir je vais regarder
mes messages sur internet
si c'était à refaire votre vie vous
referiez la même chose
oui oui je ferai le même choix que celui
que j'ai fait vous diriez la même chose
à la fille à l'époque de 17 ans vous
regrettez pas ça non
quel est le péché qui vous tente le plus
mais ça je le réserve à mon confesseur
même si je veux pas de ça
malgré tous mes efforts je n'arrive pas
à confesser mon seigneur du Falco merci
beaucoup en tous les cas merci de votre
franchise
merci beaucoup au revoir bon seigneur
[Musique]
des choses que je ne pense pas ou je
n'ai pas envie de dire parce que il faut
justifier un quota de conneries
ce chamaille on doit vous appeler
comment Rider
alors j'accueille maintenant
je m'appelle maintenant
voici maintenant Hélène
[Musique]
vous comprenez pourquoi on fait ce
métier quand même Jonas elle est assez
Catherine Catherine barman me dit dans
l'oreille elle a l'air de plaire à Jonas
oui Catherine
alors vous avez fait des films de
Fougerolles avec Jean-Pierre Mocky avec
rivet avec la Piche avec deux villes
avec cassovis avec Joffrey vous êtes on
va en parler dans le nouveau film de
Jean-Jacques benex qui s'appelle mortel
transfert et pourtant personne ne vous
connaît
pourquoi
c'est pas ça mais presque c'est vrai que
vous avez une carrière qui est quand
même maintenant à 11 ans d'existence
c'est pas rien neuf ans seulement vous
êtes prometteuse on dit hein vous n'êtes
pas encore vous n'êtes pas encore trouvé
le rôle qui va vous qui va vous révéler
au grand public et pourtant quand on
voit jouer on va parler de des films de
benex vous êtes excellentes
alors il y a eu que la lumière soit donc
vous attendiez beaucoup le film de
geoffer soit il s'est pas été un énorme
succès mais c'est là donc benex vous a
vu non il y a eu le prof de jardin voilà
ça a pas été non plus un succès énorme
la plage vous étiez la plage avec
Virginie Ledoyen et Leonardo DiCaprio
vous en couple au montage non j'avais
une grande scène qui durait deux
secondes et qui a été coupée au montage
mais j'y suis allé et je savais que ça
allait pas être tout le monde a
confiance en votre carrière tout le
monde c'est vrai
vous doutez pas j'espère regardez Jonas
il nous expliquait tout à l'heure que
lui alors c'est vrai vous avez jamais eu
une certitude absolue il savait que la
ligne y arrivait en même temps c'est
Jonas
alors votre vrai nom c'est Hélène
rigouane de Fougerolles
moi je dirais mais bon de Fougerolles et
bon aristo mais fauché comme tout
bonaristo qui se respecte
alors vous avez pensé à mon changer de
nom parce que l'année de Fougerolles
quand même vous aviez peur que ça fasse
un peu mon cul sur la commode non ouais
et aussi on me l'a proposé quelqu'un m'a
dit sur dans mon film qui veut pas
t'appeler comme ça ça fait un peu ça
fait un peu ouais grande bourgeoise mais
on a une petite tranche qui n'a pas
marché
non mais en même temps c'est c'est mon
monde c'est mon nom quelque part
franchement non moi je trouve au tableau
moi je bouge pas justement à l'école
alors à l'école en plus
c'est un mauvais exemple pour les jeunes
générations parce que ils étaient tous
les deux nuls à l'école et finalement il
réussissent tous les deux vous étiez
maigres
comment
j'étais super maigre ah c'est pas beau
et puis alors à 16 ans pareil alors vous
chez vous un jour vous avez eu marre à
15 ans en 62 jeunesse j'arrête tout non
troisième 23e 3e elle arrête tout cours
de théâtre et le rêve d'Hélène c'était
d'être danseuse au vidéo quand j'étais
petite
ouais j'ai passé de ça non c'était
gentil non parce que moi j'ai du mal à
faire des efforts
les paillettes le maquillage les machins
et puis sur scène à faire j'avais vu ça
à la télévision voilà
le soir du réveillon à la télévision et
alors comme les annonceurs ils achètent
plus d'espace entre Noël et les jours
dedans il y a plus de programme
incroyable et voilà dénoncer ça à la
télé
bien alors donc vous réalisez qu'il faut
avoir les seins nus quand on va être
dans ce joli donc
il faut les montrer et Hélène est
extrêmement pudique on viendra pas
manger hein
on est bien là tout à l'heure c'est une
soirée
tu montres les tiens si jamais on se
mange les tiens
bien alors vous vous décidez de tout
plaquer vous plaquez tout et vous allez
faire prendre des cours
m'avait plaqué avant de la prenne donc
à New York Lille Strasberg Institute
pour apprendre le théâtre mais vous
détestez de toute façon les cours de
théâtre ne sont pas plus amusés pour
dire la vérité que que l'école je
trouvais souvent que c'était des acteurs
ratés je voyais pas trop ce qu'il
pouvait m'apporter c'est très méchant ce
que je dis mais ils ont pas été très
sympa avec moi non plus donc voilà
il veut traiter un peu de godish non non
tu peux peut-être faire un truc mais
fais autre chose quoi là
métier pour toi j'étais tellement timide
que j'étais toute j'étais gourdie je
crois j'étais super timide j'avais
tellement envie que ce soit formidable
que voilà et puis en fait ici j'avais
besoin d'une personne qui me disait mais
c'est pas mal tu peux y arriver tu peux
le faire et en fait on m'a donné un
petit peu confiance et puis
les années galères les années galères
des laines de Fougerolles donc les spots
de pub notamment le film épouvantable
le petit grillé tu te souviens pas de ça
ah c'est pas le pire
en fait vous êtes obligé d'aller faire
du cinéma parce que comme j'ai de la pub
c'est le petit grillé quand vous avez
fait mannequin au début vous commencez
dans Marie-Claire ça se termine 3 mois
plus tard c'était Canigou frisky
c'était quoi biscotte
et alors les plans foireux alors il y a
un plan foire c'est physique hein pas
assez de nichons pour faire la belle des
champs
c'est clair c'est pas belle déjà en même
temps les plans foireux il y a un plan
que je suis obligé de raconter parce que
je l'adore c'est que donc un jour à
l'époque de la galère elle cherchait du
boulot tout ça il y a un type qui
l'appelle qui dit voilà je suis cinéaste
photographe mais le cinéaste aussi je
vais faire un film en septembre c'est en
septembre il lui dit mais déjà faudrait
quand même peut-être qu'on se voit au
mois de juin ce serait bien un petit
bout d'essai on va faire des photos dans
le sud au mois de juin
on était super nombreuses c'est un
énorme casting en anglais dans le monde
entier énorme film et j'avais été prise
donc j'avais décroché le rôle ah ouais
c'était un gros truc et il m'a dit on va
essayer de venir au mois de juin parce
qu'on va commencer à faire des photos
qui serviront pour le film allez-y je
vous laisse continuer
[Applaudissements]
vous prenez le train
il vient vous chercher la gare avec la
minimo et vous amène où et alors je
raconte ça donc j'arrive il vient me
chercher avec sa minimum je m'attendais
avoir des assistants maquilleuses
coiffeuse dans une superbe villa du sud
de la France je savais pas du tout où
j'étais donc c'est lui qui vient et on
passe une espèce de barrage enfin des
grandes barrières il y avait des énormes
bâtiments tout ronds et tout d'un coup
je vois un petit garçon à poil sur un
vélo
et là je me dis bon alors je vais être
un peu fatigué et tout et je vois un mec
dans une cabine téléphonique à poil et
là j'étais au Cap d'Agde le centre de
camp de nudiste
quoi je peux pas même en Bretagne je
peux montrer un sein et donc je me
retrouve là pendant trois ou quatre
jours ça a duré et lui il était une
fille et la fille c'est une bombe
atomique c'était une déesse mais elle
avait 22 ans et le mec qui pensait qu'il
était un peu vieille pour faire des
photos de nu donc il voulait faire des
photos avec vous même pour lui un peu
trop facile et alors
un jour vous partez quand vous appelez
vos parents en Bretagne oui enfin j'ai
essayé de tenir pendant trois jours
alors il fallait vous étiez nus dans ce
qu'on lui dit mais c'était horrible ces
gens étaient dans un tout petit resto
est-ce que pendant les quatre jours que
vous avez pas le fait là-bas dans un
camp de nudiste en général on est nul
quand
est-ce non plus oui il avait l'habitude
de faire la plage en long et en large
avec sa bombe atomique à poil et lui à
poil aussi et tout le monde savait qu'il
était énorme moi j'étais avec ma
serviette et genre à 2 m de la mer je
regardais je posais ma serviette
j'allais dans l'eau et je l'ai suivi en
agence c'est le retour en agence pas du
tout
extraordinaire du soir c'est qu'un jour
vous appelez vos parents qui vous
sortent de là et la fille la bombe
atomique enfin votre mère oui et la
bombe atomique la fille elle part avec
vous en Bretagne
voilà et puis après bon il y a eu il y a
eu il y a eu les premiers films et on a
parlé tout à l'heure des réalisateurs
avec qui vous avez travaillé et
maintenant on va parler du dernier film
vous savez comment on fait
bravo bien alors le nouveau benex donc
mortel transfert avec Jean-Hugues
Anglade Yves Régnier qui remarquable il
y a vous vous êtes Olga cleptomane et
maso
elle aime se faire battre par son mari
qui est donc ivrénier qui la qui la
bague espèce de promoteur alors au début
quand il vous parle du personnage dolga
donc la maso parce que le fait qu'elle
soit clepto c'est pas très grave mais le
fait qu'elle soit maso c'est quand même
embêtant au début quand il vous parle du
personnage vous
ça vous choque vous vous préférez dire
non vous vous pensez que jouer l'autre
personnage c'est-à-dire Hélène qui tu
vois une pince plutôt sympa non en fait
il m'a décrit Olga en me disant voilà
c'est l'histoire donc d'un psy qui
rencontre une femme qui est donc
masochiste qui aime se faire frapper
quand elle fait l'amour qui est il me
sort un tableau et je fais oui d'accord
et moi là-dedans il me fait pas j'ai
pensé à toi pour le rôle et c'est fou de
ma gueule je voyais ça quand même assez
je savais pas les scènes qu'il allait
mettre là-dedans mais j'imaginais tout
quoi et du coup il m'a écrit le rôle
d'Hélène
il faudrait une sacrée comédienne et ça
vous a piqué au vif et vous avez dit
mais je vais le faire alors non voilà ça
ça m'a piqué et surtout je me suis dit
bon ben si je me mets pas en danger
aujourd'hui si je fais pas des choses
qui me font peur aujourd'hui je vois
quand est-ce que je les ferai et puis
voilà vous êtes plutôt du genre à
l'étranger en basket ton porter des
talents ça doit être une expérience
extraordinaire
ce soir parce que après les scènes où
Hélène était en talent et en
porte-jarretelle après elle sera billets
vite en jean il vous demande pas votre
jule de temps en temps de mettre des
talents et des portes Jordan il vous
supporte un jean toute la tout le temps
la je sens beaucoup d'emails beaucoup
beaucoup d'emails beaucoup d'emails pour
avoir le pantalon n'en dites pas ça si
vous dites ça y est ça y est moi je vais
plus être pareil après pendant toutes
les missions c'est terrible de me
dépanner c'est vrai vous demandez jamais
à votre compagne de mettre des choses je
trouve ça mieux si elle le fait
d'elle-même en fait oui alors vous aviez
parce que vous avez une petite culotte
porte-bonheur vous l'aviez toujours
la culotte porte
vous dites c'est vrai que votre
éducation n'a pris un coup quand vous
avez tourné ce film parce qu'une fille
qui jouit sous les coups par rapport à
ce que vous êtes dans la vie
aristo catho ni rien c'est ma façon en
fait ce qui me dérangeait vraiment le
plus j'ai aucun mal à dire des enfin
voilà à dire des horreurs et à faire des
horreurs j'imaginais vraiment une scène
complètement à poil qui était dans le
scénario le mec était derrière moi
et ouais il mettait des grandes voilà et
je me disais comment je vais assumer le
truc à poil à quatre pattes en train de
prendre des coups dans la gueule vous
dites c'est un moment étrange parce que
c'est très violent et j'ai pris du
plaisir en même temps
là nous sommes au cœur de l'émission
mesdames Messieurs le climax du chaud
ça vous a plu
c'est tellement pervers c'est tellement
glauque que
j'aurais jamais assumé un truc comme ça
dans la vie enfin je pense pas que ça me
plairait donc prendre des coups et de
trouver du plaisir à ça mais là de jouer
ça je trouve certainement pervers j'ai
pris beaucoup de plaisir à faire des
choses comme ça un peu dérangeantes
c'est une façon aussi de d'apprendre à
mieux se connaître de devenir quelqu'un
d'autre et on se rend compte qu'il était
déjà là qu'il était un peu en soi tout à
fait alors vous aimez pas tellement vous
montrer nu au cinéma d'une façon
générale
excusez-moi j'espère que la citation est
vraie j'ai montré mon minou une fois je
peux recommencer
benex a essayé de vous mettre tout nu
quand même dans le film vous avez pas
voulu mais en plus je vais donner des
bons arguments parce que c'est aperçu
que j'avais raison je me dis c'est
beaucoup plus provocateur et voilà de
dire des horreurs de de me mettre à
poils
j'ai vu un reportage photographique sur
vous dans un journal pour homme qui
s'appelle FHM alors vous dites avec
cette porte-jarretelles j'avais
l'impression d'être un cheval arnacher
et pour rester dans la même imagerie
animale dit j'appréhendais ces photos
parce que j'avais peur d'avoir un côté
un peu chienne et finalement je me
trouve sexy donc là aussi finalement ça
a commencé avec le film benex
Dorcel faites gaffe je sais que c'est
bien parti vous commencez
la chienne de Fougerolles
vous commencez à y prendre goût
[Applaudissements]
même la choupinette là comme vous dites
c'était tellement mal fait comment
j'aurais pu trouver ça même à la fin
voilà alors on va voir un truc
simplement c'est est-ce que en dehors de
ce que vous faites dans ce film donc
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous avez
d'autres penchants un petit peu pervers
bien on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous dites il y a quand même un certain
plaisir à un moment à imaginer que je
pourrais l'être en gros ouais non il y a
des situations ou de quelquefois je me
demande si je le suis pas un petit peu
est-ce que vous êtes sado
ouais quand vraiment on m'embête
j'imagine juste ça le truc ouais
je sais on m'a coupé
Nicolas
et je retiens toutes les Bains comme
tout le monde je crois tous les trucs
mauvais on retient puis tous les
compliments
oui ou tout d'un coup on va me dire un
truc à
est-ce que vous êtes exibaux
les vieux de 51 ans
[Applaudissements]
Michel quelle année toi je suis 49 moi
oui quand on cherche on trouve enfin
franchement
bien est-ce que vous êtes porno vous
regardez les cassettes porno j'ai fait
un truc mieux que ça ouais c'est un
scoop j'ai doublé un film porno
c'est pas parce que j'avais besoin
d'argent c'est clapish qui a réalisé un
court-métrage porno et j'ai fait une des
actrices
je me souviens plus du texte
pour vous le la perversion passe par
l'oralité vous avez dit vous aimez dire
des mots un peu cochons ça me dérange
pas du tout j'ai pas de problème avec ça
ouais c'est dommage que je suis trop
vieux pauvre
voilà bon quel transfert de Jean-Jacques
Benek avec Hélène de Fougerolles
Jean-Hugues Anglade Robert hirenier et
Denis pas
et maintenant mesdames messieurs voici
le blind test avec mention Philippe
mais qu'est-ce que c'est Philippe
pour bien que tout le monde comprend
Didier s'il vous plaît
Ardisson c'est vrai que souvent on fait
des soirées on chante en Allemagne très
tard dans la nuit
[Musique]
c'est possible ça
monsieur parce que personne ne le trouve
tricheurs avec ses yeux noisettes de
nous endormir c'est qui monsieur
du tout Oui Stéphane
bravo bravo merci
donnez-moi le titre de la chanson
allons-y on continue chanson numéro 3
alors ça je n'aime pas alors ça va
[Musique]
je suis désolé je suis alors
bravo
pour le moment
[Applaudissements]
on a un point pour un point pour les
poissons
parce que n'oublions pas quand même que
le ce côté supporte ce côté et d'accord
en fait
tout va bien donc il râle un peu c'est
normal
[Musique]
bouge le doigt
s
tu demandes en replay petit replay c'est
très bagarré ce soir
la raison
de brunes rouges de sous la velours
maintenant c'est Serge Gainsbourg
heureusement qu'elle le reconnaît quand
même désolé quand même
mais je peux pas encore quelque chose
pour jouer Titeuf si vous voulez montrer
à quel point vous êtes bon on continue
jusqu'à la main qui chante c'est pour
vous ça
oiseaux
Nadia Moreau et Liliane Montech qui a
dit Juliette Gréco bravo voilà
comme Philippe Bull signal effectivement
4 ici et zéro de l'autre côté
comment ça va ça va je viens
je vous donne des réponses
après on remet tout Français
alors allons-y Didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont des joueurs hors Communauté
européenne
[Applaudissements]
on l'appelle ou
le son royaume aquatique
je suis d'accord Hermine Hermine je suis
d'accord ce point ne compte pas
parce que souffler n'est pas joué
vous ne pouvez pas souffler parce que
les points sont systématiquement annulés
exactement
il faut juste qu'elle respire
le scandale donc vous avez remis
derrière Titeuf c'est pas sympa parce
que ouais
Didier 8
ah j'ai rien dit
[Musique]
moi
je ne suis pas méchant
et oui bravo bravo Yannick bravo cette
équipe est formidable
hier ce soir il a eu grignoter
je suis désolé Gérard Gérard Miller j'ai
remis l'air est là pour analyser la
défaite
on continue 10 vas-y Nadia j'ai
confiance en toi
[Musique]
il y a un suspense
je demande en régie on me dit on me dit
c'est Nadia
la bouteille la bouteille
je vous demande de vous arrêter
au nom de vos qualités
[Musique]
attention attention
nous sommes à deux pour ce côté là pour
l'équipe des petites bouteilles et à 6
pour l'équipe des poissons mais
maintenant il y a le super banco
effectivement celui qui remporte le
super banco remporte tout c'est lui qui
souffre
et perdre l'équipe
Yannick beaucoup plus compliqué que
votre truc de basket c'est quelqu'un qui
chante voilà
[Musique]
Madonna non Patrick châtaigne
on a le temps
[Musique]
tu as des idées au
j'avais écrit tous nos sables pour la
mer
[Musique]
consulter vos supporters voilà
et vous revenez puis j'espère avec la
bonne réponse parce que là je
n'accepterai qu'une réponse
c'est incroyable quand même non non
[Applaudissements]
très gentiment d'analyser ce qu'elle
allait se passer donc à nos amis de
l'équipe adverse que nous avons appliqué
un vieux principe maoïste l'ennemi avant
nous reculons l'ennemi s'arrête nous
nous arrêtons l'ennemi recule nous
avançons
stratégie
je suis désolé
marche très fort les émissions
auxquelles ils participent mars très
fort voici Philippe Geluck
c'est vraiment le miel et les abeilles
on a commencé comme mannequin dans le
métier tous les deux bien sûr
alors vous participez Philippe Deluc à
une émission qui s'appelle on a tout
essayé sur la même chaîne un mardi sur
deux sur France 2 mais comme vous venez
qu'une émission sur deux finalement ça
vous fait qu'une fois par mois en même
temps mais bon parce que vous alternez
que j'ai remis l'air dans l'émission
C'est qui le producteur un peu rare qui
ne m'engage qu'une fois par mois
Catherine barman
bien alors l'émission en carton on peut
le dire on a tout essayé d'ailleurs le
dernier émission le mardi dernier
c'était vraiment avec deux Chavannes
vraiment pareil les chiffres étaient les
mêmes j'ai demandé le décompte manuel
parce que j'avais l'impression que
c'était j'avais l'impression que c'était
Bouche d'Or
alors vous participez
participer également et nous remercions
ici si tu nous regardes Michel Drucker
de nous avoir gentiment prêté une fois
par mois Philippe gay-luc et Gérard
Miller ça s'appelle Vivement Dimanche
prochain et ça c'est un dimanche sur un
voilà comme la différence alors quand
Michel Drucker vous a recruté il s'est
dit bon Miller il va faire le petit
service masure il va faire le
journaliste qui fait ça à revue de
presse et puis quand il est tombé sur
vous il vous a dit toi tu vas faire bah
écoute faut que tu trouves ton rôle
c'est génial ça vous a donné une liberté
totale oui et en même temps une angoisse
parce que c'est mot précis ont été et
toi tu vas faire trois petits points
il vous aime beaucoup Michel
c'est une organe bien alors oui bien sûr
tout était tout était tout était tout
était inventé
partir de comme disait pierre Dagh
partir de rien pour arriver à pas
grand-chose le chemin n'a pas été long
le problème c'est mesures Drucker lui a
dit je vais prendre geluk il a compris
Guy Lux
évidemment il comprenait pas pourquoi
bon en fait beaucoup de télé
et pourtant vous étiez très circonspect
par rapport à la télévision vous avez
dit une vache qui passait à la télé
c'est une vraie star mais c'est quand
même qu'une vache quoi mais oui enfin
que j'essaye de préciser
quand on pense à tous ces créateurs à
tous ces c'est peintre ces scientifiques
c'est écrivains qui travaillent parfois
sur des oeuvres monumentales et qui ne
passent jamais à la télé et qui reste
des inconnus à vie c'est un petit peu
pénible de se dire à côté de ça il y a
un crétin qui présente la météo qui est
créé un bouquin qui fait un tabac en
librairie il est marrant
on est en train de te monter une baraque
là énorme c'est bon vous le trouvez
comment
on a commencé ensemble
il avait beaucoup plus de vêtements à
changer pour se changer que nous avions
elle fait ça parce que vous avez moi
quand sur mon truc il y a encore un il y
a encore un sous-pull il a des poils
ah oui ah
en Belgique c'est une émission qui
marchait très bien qui s'appelait
Lollipop et vous l'avez arrêté pour des
raisons artistiques alors qu'à l'époque
vous aviez seulement le chat qui vous
rapporter 20000 balles par mois donc
c'est vrai que vous avez toujours été
20000 francs belges c'est-à-dire 3000
francs français ah oui c'est rien
pourtant le hip-hop en Belgique c'était
culte et c'est une émission c'était si
vous voulez du monde Python pour enfant
on a déliré pendant 5 ans en direct
alors est-ce que vous savez ce que ça
veut dire gélules en flamand
donc
vous êtes nul vous êtes nul en flamand
ou quoi là on a fait qu'on a fait que
deux ans ça veut dire bonheur bien sûr
gélules
alors votre père était caricaturiste ce
qui fait que j'ai découvert l'humour
assez jeune évidemment puisque la maison
on en parlait beaucoup vous avez
découvert akiri c'est assez jeune et
puis votre père est devenu distributeur
de films de pays de l'Est ce qui veut
dire que ce garçon
avant même de voir des films de Walt
Disney danser déjà en compagnie de Roman
Polanski Milos Forman c'est fou vous
avez kowski je veux pas dire que je les
ai fait sauter sur mes genoux
c'est étonnant pour un enfant de je n'ai
jamais vu de ma de ma vie d'enfant un
Walt Disney parce que c'était mal vu à
la maison
qui venait de l'Ouest c'était un peu
comme ça ouais il était bien il était
bonne chaud votre père non
disons
bien à gauche bien à gauche alors vous
vendez votre premier dessin à l'âge de
15 ans vous êtes très vous étiez très
très précoce à une revie pharmaceutique
vous en souvenez du premier dessin que
vous avez vendu oui c'était un type qui
n'avait c'était très cruel c'était un
type qui n'avait qu'un bras et qui
pêchait et puis il pêche un autre bras
[Rires]
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que les les
Belges sont beaucoup plus sensibles que
les Français au non-sens à l'humour
anglo-saxon oui parce que depuis
toujours on est une sorte de minorité
opprimée au sein de l'Europe vous savez
on parle français dans une partie du
pays on parle flamand dans une autre
partie on sait pas très bien on est un
peu les bâtards de l'Europe et on était
traversé par toutes les cultures par les
Anglais par les Allemands mais comme ça
voilà l'humour allemand a laissé peu de
traces dans le pays finalement mais mais
l'humour anglais l'humour espagnol voilà
tout ça ça a laissé des traces mais vous
dites que si à tous ce côté surréaliste
en Belgique finalement c'est parce que
c'est pour se délivrer de l'horreur
ambiante d'une certaine façon oui et
puis c'est un moyen de défense pour les
minorités en général pourquoi l'humour
juif est-il si formidable parce que les
Juifs ont toujours dû se battre se
défendre pour vivre l'humour tchèque
c'est pareil vous avez un chien qui
s'appelle killims qui veut dire
pourquoi il a appelé son chien qui lit
parce qu'on veut qu'ils savent plus tard
[Rires]
vous savez changer les ampoules
Naomi
comme ça vous avez dessiné vous avez
trouvé ça c'est venu comment cette
histoire de chat certains m'appellent le
Bernadette Soubirou de la bande dessinée
je ne demandais rien à personne et un
jour le journal Le Soir le grand
quotidien en Belgique m'a fait une
commande et m'a dit est-ce que tu
pourrais pas nous inventer un personnage
pour nos pages du mardi et puis j'ai
voilà je me suis mis devant une feuille
de papier et le chat est apparu
vous avez senti tout de suite vous allez
trouver quelque chose
très vite très vite quand j'ai vu la
simplicité du personnage quand j'ai vu
vers quoi il allait pouvoir m'emmener je
me suis dit j'ai découvert quelque chose
avec lequel je vais faire un sacré bout
de chemin alors j'ai noté quelques
quelques extraits de du chat
si on mettait du dans les bombes ça
soignerait déjà les premiers blessés ce
n'est pas tes mais la guerre c'est pas
de très bon goût non plus
les imbéciles prétendent que tous les
noirs se ressemblent je connais un noir
qui trouve lui que tous les imbéciles
sortent
quand je sors dans le monde il m'arrive
de dire aux gens que j'ai une grande
vessie c'est pour me donner une
contenance
hier on m'avait dit que l'avenir ce
serait aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on me dit
que l'avenir c'est pour demain quand
cessera-t-on de remettre le futur à plus
tard c'est vachement bien
mais c'est fou quand on voit tous ces
tops modèles excusez-moi quand on voit
tous ces top model anorexiques et quand
on sait ce qu'on les paye on se dit que
ça fait cher le kilos
bravo alors ça marche très très bien ça
fait 700 vous êtes à 750 000 exemplaires
[Musique]
vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle on vous l'a dit ça on va pas
bouger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez venir quand vous voulez
parce que vous ne bougez pas pendant le
jingle
quand elle rencontre un homme pour la
première fois il faut la regarder dans
les yeux sinon c'est même pas la peine
de la regarder
depuis longtemps j'ai regardé ses pieds
moi quel con qu'est-ce que vous pensez
des
qu'est-ce que
alors
Philippe Geluck vous connaissez le
portrait chinois oui le portrait chinois
c'est si tu étais une fleur quelle fleur
serais-tu bon l'anti portrait chinois
c'est plus compliqué si vous étiez une
injure
ce serait gros con ah ouais parce que
gros con c'est vraiment bien parce que
pour être un gros con il faut pas être
gros il suffit d'être con c'est vrai ça
l'avantage de vous permettre Belinda
vous suivez là oh tout à fait oh là là
très bien comment on dit gros con en
anglais alors se poser la question
précisément mais on s'est dit
bextoper
si vous étiez une maladie
la maladie de Parkinson parce que ça me
permettrait de continuer à jouer des
maracas
si vous étiez un accident
en art on parle d'accident heureux un
peintre dans le pinceau des rap crée
parfois une tâche magnifique si vous
étiez une perversion je crois que je
suis une perversion
une guerre un conflit nucléaire mondial
ça résoudrait pas mal de problèmes c'est
sur le réchauffement de la terre ça
serait réglé au moins si vous étiez un
vice
le vice sans fin inventé par Michel-Ange
une trahison
de fidèle en amitié dans le travail et
dans la vie ce serait peut-être de vous
révéler des secrets touchant Michel
Drucker ah oui
Michel Drucker et son chien oui parce
que je les vois parfois dans le bureau
et je sais qui prend les véritables
décisions
si vous étiez si vous étiez une arme
un canon j'ai toujours rêvé d'être un
canon vous en avez en face de vous
est très jolie on dit 5 canons un canon
une cicatrice si vous étiez une
cicatrice
le sourire c'est une cicatrice qui ne se
referme jamais
il est trop fort
y êtes un dictateur
le maître du monde oui parce que je fais
pas les choses en moitié donc maître du
monde ou rien maître du monde au rien si
vous étiez une infirmité la calvitie
parce que ça va c'est
l'infirmité qui a des avantages tout de
même c'est pas douloureux ça fait gagner
du temps le matin pour se coiffer et
puis ça rend tellement séduisant vous en
tous les cas ça vous a vachement bien
[Rires]
[Musique]
il ne va pas donc à l'église parce qu'il
veut pas enlever le son chapeau et quand
j'avais 4 ans à l'aéroport
il a je lui ai enlevé son chapeau il
était furieux après moi
si vous étiez un microbe la grippe
vous tombez vous êtes microbes et vous
allez vous avez la possibilité de donner
la grippe je sais pas au chanteur Carlos
ou anaomi Campbell vous hésitez pas
vous choisissez Carlos bien sûr
si vous étiez un assassin
regarde
si vous étiez un terroriste Carlos
si vous étiez une torture une torture
en même temps et si vous étiez une mort
la petite mort ah bon
bravo formidable merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu on va vous faire un triomphe
merci
beaucoup au revoir
et maintenant chacun c'est un million de
Chinois et moi et moi et moi voici ouais
ouais
[Musique]
bonsoir
bonsoir ouais ouais
bonsoir j'ai appris trois quatre mots
comme ça ni house
vous êtes aussi vous êtes très beau
très bien quelle est la raison de votre
appel
on écoute
l'histoire on a récemment vu arriver en
France les romancières chinoises voilà
on connaissait pas romancière chinoise
donc il y a miam miam qui a écrit les
bonbons chinois et il y a way way qui a
écrit Shanghai baby voilà alors on est
loin de l'épouse
soumise au pied bandés et même de la
révolutionnaire en costume Mao
d'ailleurs dans les années 50 je savais
pas du temps du maoïsme triomphant les
chinoises
avaient droit seulement à une demi-heure
de sexe par semaine avec Monsieur
cela suffisait par exemple
cela suffisait pour mes parents et et
voilà pourquoi je suis là aujourd'hui
maintenant non
on peut la considérer comme une sœur de
rencontre et d'ailleurs pendant les
années 30 c'était une perle de
Lorient et Shanghai a été comparé à
Paris
c'est pas du tout comment on imagine
c'est une espèce de mégapole
vin nocturne terrible il y a des il y a
beaucoup de musique de drogue et de la
techno un Shanghai et alors les
romancières chinoises ont cristallisé un
petit peu cette révolution alors votre
bouquin Shanghai baby là voilà je le
montre à la caméra tu sais comment c'est
ouais ouais
alors ça sort sous trois couvertures
donc j'en montre plein encore voilà j'en
montre une autre comme ça
et j'en montre encore une autre voilà
trois couvertures alors c'est un bouquin
qui s'est vendu quand même en Chine à
500000 exemplaires et qui a été pilonné
parce que ça fait un scandale là-bas
[Musique]
excuse-moi d'avoir coupé pour ça je suis
désolé d'avoir pardon pardon pardon
Didier interview vérité
[Applaudissements]
bien alors donc on va parler de vous
maintenant très sérieusement après ce
préambule sur la Chine et les
romancières chinoises vous avez 28 ans
vous êtes issu d'un milieu aisé fille de
professeur d'université et vous-même
vous êtes diplômé de littérature le
prestigieuse université de foudan à
Shanghai alors le premier scandale que
vous avez fait en Chine c'est qu'on est
sorti votre premier bouquin qui
s'appelait les cris perçants du papillon
vous ayez fait un happning vous exposiez
cette slips blancs où il y avait une
nouvelle écrite sur les slips et votre
photo comme signature c'est vrai c'est
ça
oui
peur de moi tandis que les femmes
chinoises je pense qu'elles sont
contentes de ce que j'ai dit parce que
je sers en quelque sorte à leur
porte-parole une sorte de Virginie
Despentes chinoise vous voyez ce que je
veux dire très bien moi j'essaye de pas
lire les sous-titres en même temps
bien alors ce bouquin là Shanghai baby
donc c'est l'histoire de Coco parce
qu'ils prennent des nombres ça c'est
mode de prendre des longs cocos comme
Coco Chanel elle a une copine qui
s'appelle Madonna donc voilà c'est mode
là-bas voilà la chanteuse
dans le coco à 25 ans elle vit à
Shanghai et elle partage sa vie entre
Tian qui est un jeune chinois qui est
impuissant
il est il est gentil donc Anthony de
façon on est impuissant même si on n'est
pas impuissant donc ça c'est tienne chat
qui l'aime beaucoup qui l'idolâtre et
puis Marc qui est un Allemand et qui a
une énorme sexe
pas de mettre mais avec qui elle baise
assez frénétiquement coco l'héroïne
c'est plutôt une espèce de semis
autographique autobiographie
bibliographique
bien donc effectivement le livre a été
censuré ça fait scandale parce
qu'effectivement les chinoises sont
souvent ça arrive les chinois sont pas
satisfaites et avec les étrangers ils
connaissent un plaisir peut-être un
petit peu supérieur
enfin tout le monde le sait vous dites
vous-même tout le monde le sait là-bas
il faut pas le dire encore moins
l'écrire voilà donc elle a un peu mis
les pieds dans le plat
on peut faire certaines choses mais on
ne peut pas en parler je pense que ça
fait partie de nos traditions orientales
c'est possible mais il faut pas le dire
et pas l'écrire voilà chez nous c'est le
contraire alors page 323 alors cet
Allemand l'a fait fantasme parce qu'elle
voit alors le mec il est marié qu'une
écolo qui s'occupe de la protection de
l'environnement il a rien à nazi
allemand mais elle fantane quand même
sur le côté un peu
page 323 les femmes aiment avoir dans
leur lit des fascistes dans les bottes
de cuir résonne à leur oreille ça ça
fait un peu tripes cuir tu vois c'est un
peu sm [__] cuir non
je pense que il faudrait
comprendre
je pense que pour les femmes elles ont
leurs propres fantasmes certaines
désirent même faire avec leur père déjà
page 80 ça commence j'imagine les yeux
germaniques bleu cruelle et féroces vous
excite pas à vous qu'il aurait s'il est
en costume nazi avec des bottes et un
monde un monde de cuir
en Allemagne
donc pour eux c'est un peu plus loin
voilà alors cet Allemand donc comme je
l'ai dit un organe impressionnant
et alors elle l'héroïne coco et ça l'a
fait crier de douleur
dans une situation délicate entre le
désir et la souffrance alors que toutes
les femmes cherchent à les combiner
ensemble exactement donc elle continue
malgré la taille du sexe et la phrase
j'ouvre les yeux avec un mélange de
haine et d'amour dans le regard assez
chaud très très chaud du mal à marcher
sur toi
[Rires]
pas vous mais l'héroïne coco elle
téléphone tienne donc le pauvre qui est
Jack donc il est impuissant évidemment
et pendant ce temps Marc lèche son sexe
à travers sa petite culotte on y arrive
c'est bien la littérature chinoise
d'aujourd'hui
je voudrais savoir si les hommes
français ça leur arrive de lécher leur
femme
[Musique]
bon enfin à la fin page 306 je resterai
là parce que sinon après ça c'est la
tension c'est pour ça
parce que ça veut pas durer une histoire
comme ça c'est impossible bah évidemment
lui aussi le pauvre de chagrin
bien sûr
on a déjà fait des émissions
les réactions les réactions en Chine le
livre pilonné donc détruit complètement
détruit et puis alors poursuivi vous
avez été poursuivi par des fous qui
voulaient absolument venger l'affront
fait à l'honneur national parce que bien
évidemment les Chinoises lire ça tu vois
c'est pas là-bas là-bas
plutôt je ne sais pas encore mais j'ai
entendu dire que il y a aussi un
écrivain
franco-chinois qui s'appelle cosity qui
est un grand écrivain
bien sûr
il habite dans une tour en banlieue ça
va lui faire mal d'avoir votre bouquin
sur changer les idées
alors on reste avec deux premières fois
voici Fred et Omar
tiens le ouais alors le voilà
le problème de vervid hop tout de suite
une vanne verveine qui dit mot consent
bien alors dans la nouvelle nouvelle
formule de nulle part ailleurs
vous intervenez au visiophone
[Musique]
bonsoir Nadia quitte à tenir beau gosse
en activité moi je voulais parler
d'Arielle Dombasle et BHL parce que j'ai
lu dans un journal qui se vouvoie enfin
encore c'est pas ça le pire le pire
c'est qu'il couche ensemble
bonsoir Alibaba j'appelle avec un des
voleurs parce qu'elle te donne il a dit
qu'il voulait très incarner en femme bah
il a bien raison en plus il a déjà toute
la garde-robe bonsoir Alan Waterman moi
je voulais parler des sondages de la
presse là comme quoi il y a de moins en
moins de purée en France enfin en même
temps c'est bien enfin c'est surtout les
enfants qui vont être contents bonsoir
Chappie chapeau mais du matin moi je
vous appelle parce que 42 et sa femme
ils vont divorcer attendez c'est normal
il lui a menti tout le temps il a dit
qu'il jouait au Real de Madrid elle n'a
jamais vu jouer c'est pour ça
et la moitié bonsoir prospère je suis le
roi du pain d'épices moi j'appelle à
propos de la disparition de Garcimore
franchement ça sert à rien d'être triste
pour une fois qui a réussi un tour
bonsoir Mariah Carey non vous appelle
parce qu'on a lu dans le journal que
Céline Dion elle va s'acheter une maison
au Canada
elle avait déjà l'accent maintenant à la
maison il faut y aller maintenant Céline
allez rentre chez toi
je voulais réagir parce que j'ai vu que
il y a des rumeurs sur Pascal Obispo qui
serait avec Fabien Barthez
personnellement je sais pas si c'est
vrai mais enfin en tout cas la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'ils pourront jamais
faire de gosse bonsoir Simbad marin
j'appelle ce qu'ils vont faire une
poupée Jennifer Lopez j'espère qu'ils
vont pas lui faire le même cul à la
poupée
sinon c'est les mecs qui vont jouer avec
quoi bonsoir Stone et Charden nous vous
les réagir sur Christian Clavier là
parce qu'on a lu qu'il allait jouer
Napoléon Thai Donin ego surdimensionné
tout correspond
c'est vachement bien oui
vous vous êtes donc tous les soirs dans
nulle part ailleurs une Canal+ et alors
vous êtes aussi dans le grand zapping
d'Emmanuel
gaumedis à 19h25 jusqu'à 20h45 Fred et
Omar avec Emmanuel Gaume dans plus de
zapping
on rajoute une banane on va parler
d'accessoires qui avait fait accessoires
dans C'est quoi l'émission C'est vous
êtes
c'est comment l'ambiance à Canal alors
l'ambiance
c'est une chaîne de télévision l'esprit
canal la grande famille la grande
famille de canal c'est sympa tout le
monde s'entend bien pourquoi parce que
tout le monde
qui le sait voilà aucun doit se lève on
mange pas de porc à Canal
alors Fred 26 ans Fred c'est incroyable
parce que c'est même pas dit mon âge
quand je suis arrivé à l'heure il y a de
l'info là dedans non mais 26 ans on est
à La Colle-sur-Loup
écoute-moi bien Christelle parce que
Christophe je le connais c'est mon
voisin Christophe qui est décédé en plus
hier alors qu'il est là l'émission C'est
incroyable non mais c'est ce que moi je
suis un peu tendu parce que là vous avez
parlé de son dogue de droit et moi j'ai
pas mon bac alors faut pas le dire
attends
l'affiche non bug de droite famille
bourgeoise c'est vrai quand même que
vous avez refusé par contre moi j'en ai
rien à [__] plein de thunes etc etc et
vogue la galère il faut pas que tu me
filme toi aussi
je t'aime pas
vous venez à Paris vous venez à Paris
vous quittez la Colle sur Loup vous
venez à Paris vous faites un stage
et on se dit [__] comment il trouve là
chez toi là je me dis autant Bernard
Bernard ça fait 30 ans de carrière etc
tout le monde le connaît donc c'est
normal qu'on était un faux parce que tu
as dit des conneries il a pas d'idées et
cetera Bernard on a du doc
c'est quoi vous arrivez à Paris faites
un stage à fun vous rencontrez
Eric Evans et voilà j'ai envie d'allumer
une banane parce que c'est le le Nouvel
An le Nouvel An australien il y a de la
banane
Omar 23 ans on est à Trappes
surchauffer mais bon public bottes de
Jamel et d'un nectar c'est vrai ça
non parce que faut préciser
il m'a accompagné il m'a attiré par la
main
là je vais mettre un jingle parce que
c'est la fin de la première partie de
l'interview
et là
[Musique]
je vous donne le jingle ah oui mais non
non non non rallume alors là ça fait 40
ans tu fais de la télé ça te fait marrer
parce que cette personne ne rigole pour
tout aussi c'est l'avantage
voilà 74 le choc pétrolier
voilà tu as fini de rire ça fait plaisir
non non ce que je veux dire pourquoi ne
pas bouger pendant le jingle tu me dis
ça à moi
pourquoi pourquoi sur JOUER pourquoi etc
parce que parce que voilà pourquoi pour
parce que imaginons que par exemple
Ravaillac
qui s'appelle Sophie dans les loges
qui a tué le roi imaginons que Ravaillac
et qui viennent et que vous mourriez
mourrez t'en a touché de la bonne là
très marrant
[Applaudissements]
pendant le jingle on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle voilà non mais je sais
mais j'avais pas fini ma phrase
avec 2000 par exemple s'il arrive et qui
vous tuez Thierry moi serait bien
pourquoi on ne bouge pas avant Baffie
et notoriété là on va fier de là etc
pourquoi pour qui et on ne l'a jamais
dit pourquoi on bouge on ne saura jamais
j'emporterai le secret dans ma tombe
comme l'endroit dommage parce qu'on a
qu'une vie mais moi personnellement
le secret est enfermé dans mon coffre à
la banque dans une enveloppe scellée
qu'on ouvrira à ma mort
tout le monde lève les bras une
en même temps c'est pour rigoler vous
savez que le public n'obéit qu'à moi
vous avez vu tout le monde vive les
bras
bien bossé bien alors des vannes
clientes aussi bien alors
est-ce que c'est vrai
alors qu'en fait je suis même pas énervé
pour moi c'est normal
est-ce que c'est vrai que vos parents
sont blancs et que les vôtres sont noirs
quoi
et ça vous fait rigoler
mensonge ah oui il faut dire quand c'est
oui faut dire non
vérité oui
ils sont noirs
vous a vu pour la première fois elle
vous a pas reconnu qui nous a pas
reconnu quand vous avez vu pour la
première fois Monsieur normal
enfin c'est pas normal
j'ai rien compris moi par contre ah vous
avez exigé quoi dans votre contrat avec
Canal+
non parce que on s'en occupe pas en fait
dans votre bureau vous avez quoi un
canal des plaques c'est à dire c'est un
problème
la faille de son Andreas c'est un
problème de géologie parce que la
tectonique des plaques on en parle pas
assez et ça se frotte comme ça et hop la
faille passe par canal exactement tous
les scores les vacances vous les prenez
où
mensonge toujours ou pas
le calcul
fais le calcul
[Musique]
Didier première champ alors attention
stop vous savez comment on joue
première note vous devez me dire
l'interprète sera facile pour vous parce
que c'est un spécialiste de la chanson
populaire attention assis près Jonas
près tout le monde est prêt attention
c'est très sérieux attention Didier
Dalida il venait d'avoir 18 ans vous
connaissez pas ça
va c'est vrai écrit par Pascal se vend
absolument deuxième chanson Didier
chanson numéro 3 normalement un point
pour ma fille 3 Souchon où est ce
chambre
numéro 4
Beatles
[Applaudissements]
si vous aimez les Beatles déjà
[Musique]
14 ans les
Gauloises bien
6 Delpech
[Musique]
attendez qui chante j'ai trouvé tout de
suite
[Musique]
dépêche comment tu fais 15 ans
en politique il est nul problème
là vous devez trouver ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention là c'est plus dur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les Parisiennes bien sûr avec Claude
Bolling
stop voilà donc j'imagine il a 6
schulza 1 et Jonas à 1 donc voilà vous
avez explosé alors le super banco celui
qui trouve le super banco peut remporter
le contexte alors évidemment même que ma
fille avait fait 6 ça change rien il
suffit de trouver des super banco bien
sûr c'est dur monsieur
la ville c'est introuvable
j'ai la chanson de Massimo gardias
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien les vieilles de 83 ans
c'est la chanson de Massimo Guardian
[Musique]
introuvable
de mon joli
les abeilles
83 ans c'est un chanson de Massimo
gardien
[Musique]
très bien merci on allume
donc c'est long
ma fibre bravo
c'était tout mon en parle l'émission pas
comme les autres rendez-vous dans 8
jours ça ne soit Ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu